wow
[Music]
hey what's going on you guys it's Friday
we've been pregaming a little bit a lot
[Laughter]
so this should be more fun than usual
because we're like kind of drunk
starting out a little bit a little bit
we were we were working streaming we
were doing streaming earlier yeah so we
were having like we were drinking
watching that doing that
so yeah we're a little bit
a little bit but that's okay yeah I got
um
I got beads and a pressure cooker down
there
make some refried beans yeah I think I
made it for 45 minutes and then another
20 sitting there
and then I release the pressure
Zach says Jenny I think your nickname
tonight should be Scarlett O'Hara I was
doing a whole red thing but you know I'm
like really anal retentive about
hold on a color theme you know it's like
if I have the wig I was like I have to
have the jewelry that matches and like
the outfit that matches so I was doing
like a red thing earlier I don't have
the same thing on that I had on it
on streamate but I did have the red wig
on so I decided I was gonna do a whole
red thing
so that's what I'm doing
that's what I'm doing
it was kind of a Slowdown I have to say
a little bit of a slow day we were on
for probably like a little over two
hours and I think we made like twenty
seven dollars twenty two dollars twenty
three dollars something like that
there wasn't really a lot of traffic I
kind of feel like a lot of the people
that came in today were trying to get
[__] for free
they're always trying to get you to like
do stuff so they don't have to pay for
it you know what I mean
Zach said Bread's my favorite color but
I like a more darker red yeah I've
probably read my favorite color too but
as far as like the hair and everything
goes I think the blue looks the best
just with my coloring and stuff but red
is probably like my favorite color after
black but does that even count I don't
know I don't know
it's okay just make sure everything's
okay yeah making sure everything 15
minutes be all right yeah it'll be all
right it just did you set a timer on it
or yeah okay so you'll be able to hear
it 50 minutes oh yeah it might be able
to know but then after the 15 minutes
it's got to stay for another 20.
release the pressure all right but I may
not ever have to release the pressure
it's gonna be refried beads
you can cook the [__] out of that you
cook the [__] out I'll cook your [__]
out of it yeah what you're gonna do
you're gonna put them on tacos or
something
burritos whatever they're breeding sides
Mexican side yeah I mean any of those
that'd be good we had like a couple
little small tacos earlier yeah like a
long time ago yeah cook it with some
rice and [__] but you know
we decided we were gonna eat after the
show said it before this
because like I said we were doing
streamate until probably like an hour
ago right
yeah I think we stopped like an hour ago
yeah I was telling it was kind of a slow
day over there
yeah yeah
you gotta talk you all right
not really with you let's see who's here
is actually Bath House Zach is in
yep
this is
that or a cootie Zach no he's okay
it's not tingling anymore
at all
the whole tingling situation yeah
but you know
what no I'm just saying we're just
ushering you guys into the weekend
I know it's like it's so weird like
being because I was off yesterday and I
was off today like off work so it's like
it's really weird how
much I get so I've been thinking this is
like Saturday and Sunday the whole time
I'm like what the [__] just trying to
happen I know what the [__] is even
happening because usually I'm used to
like being at work at these days
man yesterday we had like a really nice
like chill day man we were just like
[__] went and had lunch at Ichiban
yeah
then we went and saw a movie we went and
hung out at books a million got a couple
coffee drinks we're gonna do the review
of the movie I mean we could well we
might we'd do that or if you want to go
see the Meg too because I think that
started today like we could do that too
we'll see that one on Monday when it's
dead that's what I'm saying like we
could probably go because I'm off Monday
yeah because yeah I thought that started
this like last week but it didn't it
started I saw this horror movie and Jen
liked it I didn't like it it was pretty
good but um we saw a talk to me yeah
which I I feel like a lot of people like
it's Australian if you haven't seen it
um and
I liked it but I didn't think it was
like super super special but I thought
it was like pretty good though yeah I
thought it was real samey I was getting
real bored watching it kind of mind
wandering and [__] only thing I'm gonna
say is that and this is one thing I I
actually like seeing movies in the
theater better but I'm getting so
[__] deaf now that it's like I kind
of wish that they had closed captioning
they do have like shows that you can go
to that have closed captioning because
if you go to the one and actually even
are that even our [__] dinky ass
theater at that mall they do a certain
number of showings every day of movies
that have closed captioning okay so I
feel bad but it's like maybe I should go
do that because I can't hear what people
are saying and I feel like there was
like a lot of I was like I think I got
most of it I got the gist and everything
but
a lot of it I couldn't hear it and there
was nobody else well there was a couple
other people there was one guy that was
I think that was one other guy yeah I
don't think he was too impressed either
um
Zach says did you see the trailer for
the new Exorcist movie yes we did yeah
they should uh yeah Ellen Burson is back
in it I don't know how I feel about it
I'm like kind of ambivalent I will
probably go see it just to just because
I'm curious but hey
I don't know how many times can they
revisit that story well that's what I
mean they've done like a lot of other
and some of the other ones were okay
I'm not saying that but it's just kind
of I'm not talking about like the old
school one because it's like the second
one the heretic that one was terrible
yeah but um it was terrible in the sense
that it was still like so bad it's good
though like you could still watch it and
be like
no no what are you talking about that
was what the possessed lamp that was it
that was Amityville yeah that's like a
totally different video yeah now I will
say Exorcist Exorcist three was awesome
yeah
um even though it was only tangentially
related yeah to the first movie
um the other ones like the ones that
they made later on were like okay
like I didn't hate them I didn't love
them they were just kind of like there
you know yeah so I don't know if this
one is gonna be like that or I don't
know next weekend I definitely want to
go see um last Voyage of the demeanor
because that is next weekend and I'm
very excited about that that trailer
looks Kick-Ass yeah it looks good I hope
it doesn't let me know
well you know I always go into stuff
with like low expectations yeah but well
this one like talk to me I felt like it
was like you said it's a24 so I think
that a lot of horror movies nowadays are
trying to like replicate
um hereditary yeah and no one can
replicate hereditary because that [__]
was like a [__] Masterpiece easily
one of my favorite horror it's actually
one of my favorite horror movies ever
and it just came out in like 2018. so
it's like it's really really hot I don't
like I don't begrudge people trying to
do something along those same lines it
wasn't exactly the same story but you
you know you could see they were trying
to do the same thing tonally
um but hereditary was like a [__]
work of Genius you know what I mean so
it's kind of hard to like live up to
that and mid-summer too like was to the
same even though it's kind of different
but same universe
kind of yeah I think it was I think
ariaster is actually remaking
um Nosferatu okay because Tammy sent me
the trailer
and that because we just watched I'd
seen it before but we just watched the
original Nosferatu again from 1922. yeah
and yeah it's like really cool you can
see it like in 1922 that was like
blowing people's [__] minds yeah
there was more to the story
they left a lot more in yeah well it it
hewed very closely to the Dracula novel
yeah you know what I mean they didn't
put in like the brides or anything like
that and like um they didn't have like
the Extended Stay of Jonathan Harker
like at the castle and all that kind of
stuff they had to change everyone's
names and stuff but I mean other than
that it was like pretty close to the
novel they showed more of what happened
on the boat
yeah well like I said that's what I'm
excited about about Voyager the demeanor
because I'm like I just kind of feel
like nobody really
it's like look we all know what happened
on the [__] boat like Dracula killed
everybody spoiler alert so it's just
kind of like I don't know if they're
gonna do that with this movie but I was
just like well that was kind of cool
because
that was always something when I was a
kid I had um a one of those I don't even
remember what company made these but
they made like these little kind of
black and white comic books of classic
novels like classic horror novels and
stuff they had one for Frankenstein and
Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde and you know uh I
think they had one of like picture of uh
Picture of Dorian Gray or whatever which
is a great book If you ever read that by
the way
but I had a Dracula one and like the
drawings were really cool and one of the
images that stuck with me a lot from
that era was when the ship comes into
Whitby and the captain is like lashed to
the wheel and he's all [__] dead and
zombified and like whoever drew it it
was like really Kick-Ass it was like a
really Kick-Ass drawing so the guy's
like wow like he's all like [__] let
like tied to the wheel and [__] and I
was like oh that's [__] up because I
was a little kid when I had that so it's
like so I was always kind of fascinated
by that aspect of it and they don't I
mean they go into it some on the in the
book but nobody has really done that in
a movie they usually just be like yeah
and then Dracula came to England let's
get to him like eating people and all
that you know so I think it was like a
good Avenue to explore
so whoever thought of that was that was
a good [__] idea
that was a good [__] idea what were
some of the other trailers that we saw
I'm trying to remember Napoleon
no we didn't see the Napoleon trailer
not this time like yeah
um they were all horror movies no they
weren't all horror movies most of them
were there were a couple other kind of
like Indie ones or another other like
a24 ones that weren't horror movies I
didn't really I didn't really remember
they didn't really they really didn't
stand out to me yeah nothing seemed like
super super impressive it wasn't like
something I had to see right grant was
just asking something about streaming is
there real money doing streamate I'm
telling my wife we could pull a thousand
dollars a day from drinking on camera
she's skeptical I don't know about a
thousand dollars a day
um like I said we were on for probably
two hours today and we made like 20
bucks yeah and that was that was 22
bucks bad yeah it was it was pretty dead
today it was dead it was just nobody
there we were on from probably like 3 30
to 5 30 or something yeah and we only
worked about eight minutes eight nine
minutes yeah you're just waiting for
people there's a lot of people coming in
and like I said a lot of people despite
streamate being a lot better than
ChatterBait in the sense that everybody
that comes in
um has to pay you know pretty much has
to at least give their credit card
information to like for a membership and
stuff
um but people are still regardless
trying to get [__] for free so they're
always just coming in being like hey
um like we had a guy today that was just
kind of like came in and the first thing
he said was I'm a cuck sub yeah and
we're like okay that's nice but it's
like they're trying to get you to like
say some dirty [__] they want you to
talk dirty to them so they can jerk it
yeah and they don't have to pay you know
what I'm saying so we're always kind of
like very leery of like doing too much
yeah
like you want to do enough to like kind
of lure people in to like pay and stuff
joke around with them you can't just
like sit there staring at the wall but
you can't do too much because otherwise
people that's not exactly what he asked
though he wanted to know if there's real
money in it yeah there is the thing is
though is uh
thousand a day
that's like I mean I think some people
don't take that yeah yeah but you got to
be like a super hottie 18 19 year old in
at the peak hours of where it's real
busy yeah she might be able to pull that
down yeah that wouldn't be crazy but
that would be like
streaming three or four hours in the in
in the in the morning it's very busy in
the morning and then like another three
or four hours in the evening
yeah so it'd be about eight hours
probably at peak times and we're talking
about
super hot chick who's really good at
that and getting do and Young
and uh
and she's uh got a certain look that
they look for and everybody's looking
for a different kind of look but that's
a super popular
thing
18 19 20.
you know although we did notice last
night when we were scrolling through
there because we do like at various
times just as out of curiosity other
people are doing right like almost all
of the top solo women were older yeah
they were 35 Plus 35 plus there were a
couple of young ones sprinkled in there
but not many it was usually like 35 Plus
you have to stand out
yeah that's one thing you have to stand
out
and
top number one and top number one
streamer during
top hours on regular weekdays is always
this British chick who I've talked to
her she's 58 years old
and like a nine she's super hot and
she's got a
nice accent and uh she's got very high
prices I think she's like
10.99 a minute
right
and she's got a very exclusive clientele
of regulars that come and she might only
work two hours I don't know probably two
hours maybe 60 Minutes in total a day
I mean she's waiting online for six
hours yeah you're not working the whole
time most of the time you're just kind
of like sitting around like yeah people
come in the room and you're like hey
so-and-so like and then like a lot of
people just leave yeah and it you know
her rates with the commission she
probably makes three four hundred
dollars a day on a good day
she definitely probably makes
Grand a week
yeah I would think yeah Grand a week
because like I said a lot of it is just
waiting waiting like a lot of it's just
kind of like sitting around and you have
to kind of like that's why I I think
that's why we have an advantage because
you know I can just like talk to you or
we can we can just do [__] while we're
listening to music yeah we have like
music on we have like you know drinks
and [__] like that so we can just you
know we got like porn going over here so
we're like talking about that yeah and
we're like oh my God look at that [__]
you know what I mean
they come into the room it's like
somebody walking into your store yeah
and then they'll [__] get right out
what they're doing is they're just kind
of like shopping
yeah they're just going in everybody's
room seeing if anybody's doing anything
for nothing right that they don't have
to pay for right they want to see a
bigger picture of you right and um
just because they leave I mean they come
they won't come back they'll come back
yeah because some of them do they're
seeing who else is streaming yeah and
they're looking for something in
particular
they'll start talking they're asking
questions
you know or some sometimes it's just uh
banter some of them just straight up
boom they [__] hit exclusive they
turn their camera on
like we had that today
dude just turned his camera on and
[__] he was [__] going to town and
so we were just put on a show he wanted
us to um cut him out yeah I'm telling
him I was telling him that I had his
girlfriend yeah we made up a whole they
made a whole story she even brought her
here
yeah he drove me here over here and then
and then Thomas already yeah yeah yeah
so we did it we did a whole thing about
that yeah
and then see Tom's get it coming up with
that guy
I know I know you know she does
sometimes doesn't even know what it is
they're asking for well I did well no
that was just that one time yeah you're
right I mean there's a lot more of that
[__] out there well I know but like I'm
not up there I'll hit you with acronyms
I'm not up with all of them yeah they're
gonna hit you I know some of it it's
just I don't know all of it they're
gonna hit you with acronyms and there's
something for it and then there's a
certain Motif that they're looking for
um
but you know it's it's uh it's easy it's
getting really easy for me
yeah well like I said it's not strenuous
no you have to you you just kind of like
have to sit around and wait and then
like if people come in sometimes people
come in sometimes they don't like you're
just kind of have to
entertain yourself for guys that you got
to be ready at a moment's notice
yeah so
there's a certain mindset you got to get
yourself into where you can [__]
be a deaf stunt man
there's some techniques that you can use
but it does the thing is is that you're
a guy you can only go on for a few hours
then you're gonna need a rest you can
come back for maybe maybe you'll take an
hour off and then maybe you'll come but
see if they can come back for another
couple hours the thing is is that we've
never really worked any long hours
I think the longest we've ever streamed
is two hours
now I said well I think we did two and a
half one time
maybe I think that's the longest we
streamed I thought we did four hours one
time no not at once not in one go
grafter said which is more fun this show
or streamate
they're different yeah probably this is
just because we know you guys yeah
um and there's not I guess there's not
as much pressure I guess
because you know I mean because you
don't know like when people come in you
don't know what they're gonna ask for it
might be we got listeners from this show
going over there I mean I'm pretty sure
yeah like because some of the things
you know you know then I'm just kind of
like yeah
[Laughter]
not somebody when then they get out
wrong
I know who you are I mean we don't know
exactly who you are but we know
probably right but yeah but that's okay
that's okay like I said we did have one
person
that um they might be listening now they
listen all the time but um we do have a
regular account okay that came in there
yeah and that and that was actually cool
because we could talk to them about [__]
because they said who they were and I
was just kind of like oh yeah I remember
yeah we did a show we did a show for him
for probably about what 10 minutes yeah
it was a long time it was a long one I
don't remember what we did exactly but
yeah we did like a long trip I remember
yeah I lose track
of like what what we do for various
people yeah
and the weird thing about it is that
some people I'm like some of the people
we had today like they would like pay
for
like exclusive and then they wouldn't
ask for anything yeah I'm just like what
exactly
we're trying to help you out here like
what exactly yeah
they were getting enough I guess
yeah I guess like we'll do some [__]
just that we want to do if that's right
okay that was good enough I guess but
it's like some people don't ask because
usually we're like What do you you know
what do you want like we'll do what you
want like within reason you know what I
mean but
some people don't Zach said y'all ain't
never seen me in there
it's actually the funniest thing I saw
in a cam show was a dude with one of
those toys up his ass talking about
something normal then someone buzzed him
and he falls to the floor screaming
it's like I have this thing on my butt
and then oh [__] like somebody [__]
yeah yeah that's over the men's section
who is asking if
what was John asking Joshua said I think
it a little odd going over to the other
show a little intrusive or is that just
me I mean we don't really care well no I
mean it's everybody's has their own yeah
thing about it like I said it's not
really that weird it's not that
different I mean from my point of view
it doesn't seem that different and like
I said we're not doing anything crazy
like in the
guest chat in the public chat yeah
because like I said we're trying to get
people yeah we're in a public chat most
of the time yeah most of the time we're
just trying to we're trying to get
people to pay like we'll do [__] for
that and like you know anybody can't see
that you have to right then it goes into
private and then you have to go in you
know and it'll say if you click on us
it'll say oh they're in a private chat
they'll be back in a minute or whatever
um I got used to it pretty quick I don't
care if I know you or not
yeah it's like it's weird I'm not
bothered I thought I would be bothered
but I'm not no I'm not
I don't know why I'm not bothered I've
just
I don't know why I thought that I would
be bothered
I don't know it's it's very strange it's
very strange I don't know I don't know
what the whole thing we'd be in the
public chat [__] doing some crazy
[__] but they can't you can't see it
well you have to be kind of sneaky
because you can't catch it I mean I
don't think you'll get in trouble just
like people they won't shut your stream
down just because we see people doing
crazy [__] especially especially
especially the Columbia they'll just do
anything they'll do anything but if
somebody reports you yeah then you'll
get trouble you're getting a suspension
you can suspended for a day so I'm
always just kind of like well we'll try
to keep [__] on the safe side but you
like I said why would you want to give a
free show though that's what I'm saying
so I we do try to kind of keep it like
so it's like suggestive it's like oh
like we're doing something like kind of
on below the level of the camera or like
over here where my head's blocking right
or something right or something like
what she's doing right or something like
that and it's like hey if you go
exclusive like you'll be able to see
what we're doing what's going on right
then we'll do that so so then it looks
like we're doing something and people
are like oh I'd like to see more of this
I'd like to subscribe to your newsletter
or whatever it is and we are doing
something well yeah we're not faking it
yeah yeah
because like I said sometimes we're just
kind of like well nobody's coming in
here so we're just gonna entertain
ourselves you know she's looking good
I'm looking good the [__] music's
going and [__] you know
porn's going and we're kind of like
we're drinking and we're just kind of
like a height in the sense of what the
hell's going on and uh you know it's
just like
being on a porn set or something you're
gonna need fluffing
so yeah that'll be full of some fluffing
all kind of the fluff and [__] but like
I said we can't like show anything right
you can suggest things like I said if if
a body part is blocking it or it feels
like underneath the level of the camera
then it's okay like nobody can do
anything but
so we try to like work around it so I'm
always like looking back like can you
see anything
Joshua said so if somebody asked Tom
drop dress up as little bo peepee be
cool with it asking for a friend address
up is fulfillable beat yeah he'd
probably do that for a certain amount of
money yeah I
yeah it would not be a convincing little
movie
it would be funny though yeah it would
be funny though I just laughed
[Laughter]
well we did have somebody come in yes
this is we'll see okay this is one thing
this is why I suspected that this was
somebody from the show because somebody
just came in and that just without any
Preamble or anything like that they were
just like pegging yeah I just started
laughing I was kind of like oh you
[__] I mean Maybe not maybe
they're just like asking that just
randomly because they were into that I
said yeah sure I Peg you
and he started laughing because I'd love
that [__]
I mean yeah
yeah but then he left though because he
was just they just try to get you to
talk dirty to them yeah that's what I'm
saying like 90 of the people are just
trying to get you to do that [__] you
can you can interact for a few seconds
but then you kind of want to you want to
throw it out there and [__] well we
could work something out [__]
um we'll go we can go exclusive for this
amount this and that [__] just more
like you started handing out prices
to get them to press to [__] go
exclusive button yeah
um you don't want to sit there and just
I'll laugh about some of the [__] they
say but you don't you don't feed into
that start talking dirty unless I'm in a
really good mood some dudes have said
some [__] was [__] funny as [__] yeah
so I just started throwing throwing it
back at him you know what I mean if I
could and then like I said you can't see
too much you can't do too much because
they're over there just like yeah we're
just yeah they're getting there for a
friend they're just like jerking it for
free yeah it's like you gotta pay
[__] yeah we're not sitting here
for our guys you know what I mean
um grather said the Colombians do anal
get feces all over then wipe it up with
TP it's most nasty oh my God I'm glad I
never saw that we did see like one we
were looking through there they're not
all this not all the Columbians are the
same no no yeah like well I mean there's
a lot there's just a lot of Colombians
and they got look man Colombia
growing up in Brazil
Colombia had a huge reputation you know
America's always talking about how hot
Brazilians are well Brazilians are
always talking about how hot Colombians
are
all right and [__] in in South
America
Colombia's [__] has a reputation for
just having the best looking girls and
they just grow on trees
and we've we know a Colombian girl yeah
she's super super hot and they're just
real femi and real and they're kind of
aggressive
uh
South American women are usually the
aggressors not the men they're kind of
like aloof to that that's like not Macho
to
go after them too much they're like I'm
gonna chase the [__] I'm just gonna
come together like that too much
I'm too cool for this yeah exactly
they're like that a lot you know the
girls will be piling on yeah the good
ones are like that right The Good the
good South American guys are like that
they're not simps they don't [__] sip
it's Macho
but uh yeah so they got Colombians and
the problem with the Colombians is that
they're they're poor
which means you give them a five dollar
tip they're [__] that's a lot of
money in Colombia
so they'll just do [__] well you can get
some rules in public
just so passers-by just tip them a
dollar
or two dollars
[__] putting on whole shows you know
what I mean in in the public chat
something that really a customer should
pay a hundred dollars for
well we were what we were going through
there last night yeah and there was a
Colombian couple and they were just
straight up [__] straight up [__] and
in public
and I mean maybe that works for them for
them I mean it works as long as they
don't get reported I guess it's because
like I said technically you're not
really supposed to do oh that's against
it do it I think they just live their
normal lives and then they go okay let's
[__] and turn the camera on let's make
money off of it right because you can't
run a whole show like that
yeah you'll exhaust yourself right see
the thing is is that when we're doing
these little shows that are five ten
minutes long 15 14 minutes I think it
was the longest one we ever had
you can't really climax in that show
there's not much you can just the
customer does
well yeah that's you gotta work the rest
of the night ideally yeah you're just
trying to get that person off because
they paid that's what they paid for yeah
so it's like whether you get off or not
as immaterial you can get off after this
it's constant for me and Jay are just
basically going through constant
foreplay right the whole shift that's
what I mean now that one dude that paid
for like 15 minutes that dude was a lot
of fun yeah because he gave us a better
show than what we were given he was a
[__] trip that one man well he was
like super into it yeah I was like
giving a thumbs up and [__] [__] and
he's like yeah he was super into yeah
and he was he turned on his cam he was
like all pretending yeah like dude he
was doing all the motions and stuff and
I'm like wow look at that dude go and he
was
um no slouch he was spout yeah he was a
good looking dude probably about 25 26
and he could have competed easily in
ifbb men's fitness he was I don't know
why he's not doing streaming yeah he
could have easily been a porn star or or
a streamer yeah he was shredded as [__]
and he was built and he was having fun
Ginger beard and [__] short hair and
you know and I'm [__] putting on
got Jenny's legs up [__] dude
hear him make cop making comments but he
[__] jumped out and started doing a
one-handed push-up swipe is jerking it
[__] dude
yeah he was having a good time yeah but
that was really fun yeah he he put on a
big show
he wanted he would have paid money to
see that he wanted me to yell his name
yeah yeah Jennifer's name out
that's funny which I was like okay yeah
that's another thing is that
um
we don't take it we have we have fun but
we don't take any of this personally
that dude well I mean you can't you
can't it's part of your job it's just
it's just it's all entertainment and uh
it is over and like we've forgot about
we forget about it almost instantly it's
not like a traumatic experience for us
or anything is it no I don't know yeah
it's like we're no longer civilians like
we were kind of worried man so we might
turn the camera on we might not like
what we see every dude turned on the
camera so far was just a normal
guy yeah they were all like pretty like
they were all like good looking good
decent decent to good looking yeah well
like I said I I feel like people that
are really don't want to be seen on
camera wouldn't turn their camera they
don't turn the cameras on so people that
know they look okay they're like okay
yeah and it makes perfect sense
these are young guys
it's hard to tell what part of the
country that they live that they live in
they're Americans
they're in good shape
so that and they turn the camera on
which tells me that they want validation
yeah they want credit for the work that
they did you know because they're
working out
and so they're trying they're they may
be in a situation where they don't get a
lot of attention depending on where they
live and no one ever gives them credit
for looking good yeah it could be that
and so they get instant validation
by other people that look good going
yeah man you look oh you did a great job
you know [__] you know yeah he said
he was bi also right yeah that's another
thing is that we don't really care we
get a lot we actually get a lot of buys
but men yeah buy Fitness type guys
and which is not strange when you think
about it like because that they're
looking specifically for a couples I'm
guessing yeah they're looking for
couples and they they like couples that
are in decent shape and uh
the
and we we don't really care who's
getting off on who I don't care if the
dude is looking at me or Jed [__]
that's my job I'm there to [__] help
this dude like I said I have a little
[__] experience and then we get paid
for it and [__] all and he's like
I'll be back later okay yeah come on
back we want him to come back
we actually got a lot of we um we got
reviews and [__] 11 favorites just from
this last stream
so we're now at 80 something the one we
just did yeah we got 11 faves so we're
now at like 80 something no I found out
what happens
when we have enough favorites or
followers then then we can raise our
prices above yeah because at the moment
we're new we're only capped F you can
only do 5.99 a minute that's the highest
you can do and that's so we have
everything at the highest point you get
more of them you can raise your own
price you can raise your prizes right
yeah that's how they do it like the more
the more you're on and the more people
review you and [__] like that but we did
get up to five stars so that was good
yeah
we did get some good reviews
Raptor says the Colombian dudes are
mostly limp because they nut ten times
today
yeah I don't know it's just they're
they're they're [__] um grifting
basically a lot of it is a scam you know
some of the [__] that me and Jen do
some of it is [__] illusion
all right yeah but like I said we're
just trying to but the customers don't
care yeah yeah
they're again what they're getting is
they're getting Interactive
on-demand porn
basically yeah and they can ask for [__]
and that's what she used within
everything around right and some guys
have said [__] they want what camera
angles they want is it can we can you do
doggy [__] a frontal view I just want
to see your face just want to see your
your tits I want to be able to see you
your your head above her [__] no okay
fine I know exactly yeah right because
you let's go now okay which he's already
told me that I know I was what he he's
telling me we're gonna get this over
with because I got my [__] in my hand
all right because it doesn't matter if
you're ready or not yeah I am I'm giving
you a camera angle where you can fake it
all right so I say okay yeah we do that
camera soon okay because that means he
was experienced he'd been playing stream
mate sure this is a game the customers
do it
are regulars they do they spend a lot of
money but yeah like I said some of these
people obviously spend a lot of money
when he placed the order he even gave me
the camera angle [__] it says yeah I
can do that right now yeah so that way I
didn't have to wait for some food five
minutes ten minutes for everything for
through the fluffing process because
he's running around you know that
motherfucker's looking at my crotch he
knows I'm not [__] ready
and got that one done and that was uh I
think uh 10 minute show I think
although the shows don't last long
they're five minutes to 15 minutes yeah
I mean people don't want to pay like a
hundred dollars yeah they just you know
if you're 5.99 a minute they're gonna
try and get in and out in like five ten
minutes so they don't spend all their
money right and they're they're not
stupid they know that
for the performer nothing happens in
five minutes she's not gonna [__]
come I'm not gonna come it's just well
like I said they just want something to
look at yep
so there is an element of
I don't want to say scab it's not a scam
they're getting what they want is
there's yeah it's just like there's a
very element of fantasy sure that's all
it is that's it and everybody knows what
the deal is yeah nobody's like asking
you although I will say that we got a
little bit into it and there was like
some real [__] going on like even in the
free section yeah I mean you couldn't
really see anything you couldn't tell
they knew we were and they were coming
in looking for a little bit but it was
funny there's a way to see who people
are looking at you who are not in your
room because if you're not signed up to
stream mate
you can watch the channel they kiss
it that person doesn't
it's not it doesn't isn't shown to us as
a member who's just come into the room
it shows you as a [__] it shows them
as a potential customer it's at the
bottom they can't they can't talk to you
or anything
you can't talk to you there's somebody
that doesn't have a membership they can
still like come in and see what you're
doing and you're free so you got people
who are thinking about John industry
mate looking at performers well we can
see that how many people were looking
and when that was going on five people
were watching right they were getting a
little bit of a free show but they
couldn't it was it was it was uh R-rated
though
yeah you couldn't see it you couldn't
really see anything
but it was actually like yeah they knew
it was up though that's why they were
[__] five of them we call them
peeking in the window
because they're not because they're not
like signed up to stream me but you get
like one stuff for free yeah
John Smith says wow Columbia sounds
really affordable
I mean I guess
there are really a lot of like I said if
you go on streamate like looking for
this app I would recommend we usually
just kind of filter out all the Columbia
not because we don't like Colombians
it's just that there's like there's so
many of them there's four [__] pages
of Colombians because they're always on
there's a filter you hit filter and you
go and you just press
U.S UK Canada Australia that's one the
top section that's the English-speaking
world just hit that and you'll see just
them and there's never any more than
about 250 streamers in the in the in the
English-speaking world
it's mostly about 50 on it once yeah
it's not as big as ChatterBait but it's
more curated that's why we like it
better no we haven't got any shitty
people so that's nice yeah we've never
even really been trolled no the um not
so far no actually it's like somebody
tried to troll
and I I laughed so hard I could think he
thought it was funny too he stopped
trolling and left yeah you were sitting
there [__]
pulling on it or something through
through my [__] shorts since he goes
That's What viagra's for and I went yeah
I was like
[Laughter]
but that was a good one though yeah
um you just can't I mean you can't let
[__] get to you but like I said we
haven't had anybody come in and say
anything [__] yeah like that it does
seem like most of the people in there
are there because they want to be there
yeah well it's like looking for well
here's the thing the members
guys that are signed up in there that
have been in there for a long time have
bought videos and all kinds of stuff
from performers that they watch on a
regular basis
and they kind of collect they're kind of
like Head Hunters when new people show
up they want to jump in there and they
want to get videos and they want to
[__] play with them
it's kind of like collect them all you
know what I mean right they got guys
that are like that well if they get out
of line they'll get their account
suspended and they'll lose [__]
access to all the little videos and [__]
that right
so everyone's kind of on their best
behavior yeah yeah and they'll they'll
and they'll lose the ability to come
back in so they don't want they don't
want to get kicked off the platform
yeah so I do kind of feel like most of
the people there like I said that's why
it's better it's curated and you can
block a member yeah you can kick them
out of your room you can like yeah they
don't even know if you're existing once
they're blocked you've you vanished to
them that and they don't want that they
want they want the ability to come back
so
the streamer
the performer has a lot of power
over the customers
you can just vanish a customer
from your site yeah they don't they
don't really want that
you could also just kick them out of a
room yeah they go into come into the
room they don't say anything for too
long you know nothing about just pulling
this putt and [__] trying to get a free
show you can
you say we've done that a couple of
times because we try to like talk to
people like Tom tries to talk to people
and they come hey where are you from
like what are you up to what do you want
us to do what do you do yeah and some
people just like sit there and like
alert yeah so what you do is you just
wink and kick him out
you don't have to block him
but it's like you're not going to talk
yeah if you're not gonna interacting you
you can't hang out in there right no
it's like I don't want people like
hanging out in there for 20 minutes like
not [__] some of those some of those
creepy some of the real hottie female
performers get basically
they're like damn oh it's like a female
frog with a million male frogs trying to
jump on her
and she's running her
her laptop and she's kicking them out
four or five at a time
for not talking
because you got too many of them in a
room she just wants ones that are paying
customers that are going to pay and
they're going to pray yeah but like I
said you just don't want a bunch of
people that are just like lurking they
won't answer you and you talk to them
and stuff it's like that's kind of
that's kind of yeah and then I've seen
them I've seen him go no you know if you
don't tip then I'm gonna kick you out
and then you'll see like a couple of
ones I mean that's a little harsh but I
can see how people I can see how people
would get to some of the streamers their
whole thing is to be pretty and [__]
and and dudes will throw money at him
maybe actually like it maybe I should
get real [__] and real you know oh no
no no no real demanding I can do super
content yeah well you've had him come
and say [__] yell at me but then you
yell at them and they don't give you no
money that's what I mean yeah so it's
like don't maybe try to do [__] for free
I don't like that
uh hi there Legion Reaper this is a new
person you guys have like a ChatterBait
Channel but on streamate or this like
only fans
um we we don't we stream on streamate we
don't do ChatterBait because it's just
too many That's like [__] in the
Roman Coliseum yeah I don't really like
the idea of that where it's just kind of
like hey let's [__] in public and then
every now and then somebody will give
you a dollar [__] that right yeah
streamate is like a lot better yeah
because you don't have to do anything
like super egregious in public but
ladies and private Ray like people can
pay you like we do 5.99 a minute and you
do 5.99 in a minute and then they can
ask you for [__] and you can do a
private so like not everybody's watching
you so I kind of like that better
uh so we do that and we also have
um many vids we have some videos up
there that we saw also
so but yeah we looked into it like we
researched this a long time before we
actually did it
and stream 8 seems to be the way to go
like I said it doesn't have as much
traffic as shutterbate but it's more
curated when we get to Twitter going we
got to Twitter we just got to get we got
to put stuff on you got to put some [__]
on it the Twitter Twitter will have
links to
our material yeah because like we don't
we don't do it that often now because
I'm still like working a full-time job
we did a couple hours today before we
did this show
um you know and sometimes we'll do it in
the evenings or on weekends or something
like that when you have time but
hopefully we kind of want to do it full
time eventually
so that's kind of what we're shooting
for yeah the full-time Lifestyles it is
pretty good
yeah because it's not like I said you
don't a lot of it is just sitting around
waiting for people
but you got a real flexible schedule
yeah no commute so there's no expenses
yeah but you can just like jump in and
out yeah like whenever because I mean
today was not gonna lie like kind of
slow like we made some money but not a
lot
um so we streamed an hour too long we
should have got off
yeah as soon as but we were having fun
yeah I mean we're traffic started to
slow down you can feel it slow down
people weren't here and you're like okay
like I said there there are high traffic
times and low traffic times it's just
kind of an ebb and flow and it's summer
the summer is slow we're trying to get a
feel of when the best
times are yeah so we're just kind of
trying it different times winter was the
best is the best time is it when a lot
of a lot of the world is indoors because
they're frozen in yeah also
mornings and early afternoons and
evenings real late yeah we just didn't
get our [__] together early enough today
we didn't get on until like 3 30. but um
we've been streaming
48 minutes okay
Zach says okay but can Jenny be
Elizabeth Salander and Tom can be Daniel
Craig asking for a friend
oh my God I could be Elizabeth olander
like pretty easily I don't know about
Daniel Craig could you could do Daniel
Craig right I don't know
that's weird
not with this beard not with this beard
no and I kind of like the beard I
couldn't do that Daniel Craig but his
beard he didn't have beard I never said
beard off that's what I mean don't
understand if I kind of like it I like
it
I didn't know I was talking to him the
other day because I was just kind of
like I wasn't sure if I would like the
facial hair on you but now I like the
facial hair honey and you said that you
were at where were you at the other day
Starbucks or yeah it says or somewhere
and
he should like because I guess is it the
girl that works there one girl that
works there one of the girls work so
yeah
um she's only ever known him with the
beard yeah so he was showing her
pictures from before when he didn't have
a beard because I
the beard is very recent yeah I showed
her what I look like without a beard and
with hair and she was like
what the [__] is that about and it's
just like hilarious because it's just
kind of like well for 95 of our
relationship you had hair hair and not a
beard right yeah so I'm just used to you
like that but it's just kind of like she
didn't go huh she just she's weird she's
like that because she only knows
that's just super funny just he's just
like she's like I just can't pitch you
like that
well like I said that's how you looked
most of the time and I said what you
like better because no I like it like
this better yeah because that's what she
was used to that's what she used to yeah
I like it that's why I like both I like
both ways I look totally different I
mean I know I look totally different but
yeah you do yeah totally you do
but it's you know I mean as as you age
you can't keep that same look
you know what I'm answering my 30s and
40s you got to be flexible yeah and
thirds and fours that look pretty good
until I started getting into my [__]
50s it's late 40s and late 40s and that
kinda that kind of looked doesn't really
look as good you know on a guy who's
kind of getting older you you got to get
Jack to get bald to put some facial hair
on and get [__]
yeah yeah it's life is a lot easier when
you look like this it's a lot easier
true I get that man I was sitting there
at [__] Starbucks and [__] and I was
looking at my tablet and there was
way down there by your dick like that
yeah no I was like
the tables there and my helmet was on a
little round table
and um
there was people waiting in line to get
[__] right and some
guy I guess he was I don't know 18 19 or
sitting right here around [__] his
ass it's right here in my [__] face
forever and I just that [__] that
[__] went on for a few minutes and I
just [__] grabbed it look look look
get behind me get behind me
let's get behind before I get mad and he
didn't know what what it was
but you know what I mean his ass was
right here and I almost not look at this
dude's ass what if he first he might
fart
or something he was he he's either gay
and trying to get my attention which I
he didn't I didn't have him pegged for
that or he was just totally
I don't think people I don't think most
people it was spatial awareness I don't
think most people are aware of where
they're close pointing yeah he was so
close that I didn't all I had to do was
just [__] grab him by the elbow right
there and you just look you get back
there
before I get mad and that was all I said
and that shut down you can't do that
until you can just beat the [__] out of
somebody that's when you could do that
you know how to beat the [__] out of
that dude
but I just didn't like him that close to
me I I got a [__] Space Bubble I
don't like [__] people getting in my
space no I don't like that if you're in
within an Arm's Reach I see you as a
threat
you've invaded my I mean unless that
dude from [__] from [__]
Frighteners you ever faded my space
bubble
I'm kind of like that too yeah yeah I
mean unless it's a situation where
everybody's crammed in like if we're in
a crowded subject or something like that
okay fine it's like I understand yeah
but it's like if there's plenty of room
if we're in the store and there's plenty
of room I don't want your ass in my face
I don't want your face my face I don't
want anything in my face just get the
[__] away from me yeah there's Ram yeah
it's just kind of like you know you know
how this happens you know how you go to
a movie theater for example
you're sitting in there there's nobody
in there there's like only a handful of
people in there or whatever some
[__] or a pair of [__]
will come in and sit right behind you
why why the [__] people do that yeah
well because you got the center row and
you got the best seats they're gonna get
the second best right but I'm just kind
of like do I look like a person that
wants some [__] sitting right
behind me I am not that person I'm like
y'all gonna talk the whole time and I'm
gonna have to want to turn around and
like hit you I don't like it
there's all this room it's probably like
different now because now you have to
like reserve your seats
back in the day you didn't have to you
just come in and it was first come first
serve so you just come in and like sit
down the regular sheets but there was
always some [__] that would like
sit right [__] behind you or right in
front of you which is even worse
but right behind you is about a tail
because then you don't know it's like
what the [__] does this [__]
want why are they just like right
like there's tons of room I don't know I
always go to a place and I'm just like
I'm okay I'm gonna get like as far away
from the people that are already here as
possible even if it's a shitty seat I'm
gonna check my uh pressure cooker
Zach said what if you did a show where
you cross-dressed and pretend to be each
other that'd be hilarious oh my God I
would actually love to see
actually I don't know if I'd love to see
it because it might be really it might
be really bad but um I I would love for
Tom to like dress up as me for Halloween
and like act at like me for Halloween
and just see because I'd be curious to
see like how he would perceive me
I don't know I would probably be
brilliant it would probably make me
really mad
I kind of because I can kind of picture
what he would do and it's like it would
probably make me really bad because I'm
like oh you're such an [__] although
to be fair if I was dressed up as him I
would probably like amp up the [__]
also so he would probably also be mad
if I tried to do that
yeah John Smith said the beard bald
combo does give Tom an Anton LaVey Ming
the merciless look I actually just
called him being the merciless earlier
that's kind of what he's going for I
think
Is We I still think that he should dress
up as a merciless too
Legion says you guys gonna pick like
porn names and stuff nah we didn't do
that we just I mean we didn't use our
real real names like on the show I mean
you have to like when you go in like for
the legal [__] but
we just used we wanted it to be sort of
related to
this show but not super super related
you know what I mean so there was like
so you knew that there was a brand thing
but the thing about streamate is that
they won't let you because I wanted to
Brand it with something with 13 in it
but they're like yeah we won't let you
do any number in your name that is lower
than 18 because they don't want to
encourage any uh you know underage kind
of stuff like they don't want any
suggestion or any whiff of anything
having to do with underage so they
wouldn't let me do 13 anything like it
was a number if it was spelled out or
anything
so over there we just had to do I think
it was Jen tomcam or Tom gen cam or
something like that I don't remember
what it was and um but we did do 13 km
for
Twitter and also for
many vids I think they let us do it so
it's called that but
John and Tenney LOL
yeah I was saying that um
okay hold on let me say something first
though what you all remind me in 20
minutes I go I gotta go down there and
release the pressure off the damn
instant pot is it gonna explode if we
don't no it'll just overcook the beads
um wait what time is it now 8 21 so at 8
41 yeah right there around 8 40. Eastern
Standard Time 84. maybe I should write
that down because otherwise I'll forget
because I've been drinking a lot today
so I'm just kind of [__] they got clocks
they'll remember
they got clocks we got clocks I'm just
saying
I was saying that
because Zach was suggesting that we
dress up as each other and I was like
I'm not sure that like if you dress up
as me for Halloween and acted like me
for Halloween it's like I probably get
really mad
understand you want to see me in a week
oh [__] he's doing wig [__] they should
be right there
you're gonna become coming in Tammy says
okay 20 minutes thank you Tammy I mean I
wrote it down but I might forget so
if I have a clock right there but I'm
like looking at it
so I might forget about it
yeah Samantha said I don't want anyone
near me either gross goes for the beach
and the pool too yeah exactly like I go
anywhere like in a public area I'm like
where are all the people I'm going the
opposite direction I don't want to be
behind around anybody ever
yeah Zach said I don't get the big deal
with the front row seat at a movie who
wants to look up and have the movie look
all
uh Parallax the whole time yeah it's
like I have sat in the front if the
movie was kind of crowded and there was
like nowhere else because I want to sit
where there's like a big Space Bubble
like around me you know what I mean so I
have sat in the front before but I don't
love it you know
ours our ideal spot is like you know
like the front section and then there's
like that big walkway we like the seats
in the middle like where our backs are
to the walkway so then like nobody sits
behind you but you're still in the
middle but you're not like super super
close so we usually try to get those if
we can't get those then we'll go like a
couple over or one back so at least
there's nobody in front of us you know
John Smith says pressure cookers for
when you want a needless element of
danger when you cook
yeah pretty much yeah it's a steam
powered bomb I mean they're better now
than they use well they're supposedly
safer now than they used to be right
I remember being [__] terrified my
when my grandmother would use when I was
growing up and I was like I was like are
you using the [__] pressure cooker
I'm gonna go in the other room hopefully
there's like several walls of concrete
in between if it blows up oh [__]
[Laughter]
he's he's doing he's being uh Glenn
Danzig or like kind of like cross
between Glenn Danzig and one of the
Hidden members of venom okay I like that
better right yeah you're like a much
hotter cooler Glenn dancing
oh man
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
hold on what's he doing now I had to put
the uh
yeah I was gonna say don't put the uh
the brush away okay
and don't leave that damn door open
because yeah
she yelled at me earlier like hey open
the closet door but then like I opened
the closet door and then she looks at me
like what the [__] are you trying to
pull like I think she thinks that
there's like gonna be something super
special that I'm hiding in there but
there's not
there's become like Commander Krug from
[__] you're so pretty Tom
like a [__] Klingon
you need a bigger forehead yeah yeah
where's the weight is the part in the
middle or yes okay all right
yeah I look like that's a comrade
you do actually look like a Klingon with
it when you just push it back like that
yeah all you need is like a little Ridge
right there yeah
oh my God we're gonna do that on
streamate one of these days we're gonna
we're both gonna dress up like I'm gonna
be a Klingon too that'd be cool
[Laughter]
me are there any wigs to where Tom can
be very Gib
we don't have a i don't even have a wig
that looks like that do I
no
because he was the one Barry Gibb had it
was parted in the middle right and it
was about what shoulder legs I can't
really remember
it was a 70s haircut and it was kind of
brownish I don't even have one I don't
even have one like that
you have that one you have the Joe Dirt
wig like the mullet yeah
you have the Mozart wig which we haven't
seen in a while actually you have a
K-pop wig although you don't tell
anybody about that I forgot about the
Capo
I put that on the show
yeah a long time ago yeah a long time
ago you should put on some of my wigs oh
why don't you put on my because I have
like a Wednesday Adams black braid one
the Blackberry not good I'm heavy metal
right now okay well if you wanna if you
want to be Wednesday Adams later you can
be see she's trying to gender swap me
well we'll see how that now if I'm gonna
do anything I'm gonna go in there and be
Bane
you're gonna go bring the brain mask in
Legion said Tommy got this Tommy wise it
looks
a little bit
somebody I mean I don't know who that is
you know it was the guy that did the
room I didn't see it oh my God
you're tearing me apart Lisa I need to
see it oh my God I can't believe you
don't know about that
I heard it was like the worst movie ever
um if you mean most hilarious movie ever
yeah what was it bad or was it good
it was terrible but it was terrible in a
way that was like really really
entertaining
so I guess it's kind of good
we should probably watch that one of
these days oh yeah I feel like that's a
large gap in your cultural understanding
yeah
oh hi Mark
I mean he doesn't even know about that
looks like the male
version of the Farrah Fawcett blowout is
what made it okay I remember that thing
the thing where it came out like oh yeah
[__] okay okay so I don't have anything
like that then yeah
I don't even have anything like like
maybe that's something we should look
into oh maybe we should get like some
Charlie's Angels wigs why I don't know
just because you got bell bottoms we
could be that's what I mean we could be
Charlie's Angels except only two of them
we have to get another person to be the
third one
why am I the woman all of a sudden you
can be you can be Farrah Fawcett and
I'll be um because I said yes to little
bo p and all of a sudden she's kind of
General swab me
[Laughter]
even crustled you know Eva did the movie
when he was in drag
you know I'm not worried about it
you're not worried about it no I don't
care
I don't care
no I don't care
what was it that somebody said like to
us on streamate today that they asked
for it and then they were like It's Only
Gay what did they say it was begging he
said it was okay it's only a gay if you
come inside yeah I said okay yeah I
guess I did okay
well like I said that's just kind of the
whole thing well we were watching the
porn we were watching
was was it Sophie
we watched it with Sophie D and the one
that she had like two dicks in her mouth
right but the dude's dicks were like
touching and Tom was like oh that's gay
yeah
I mean they were both Sophie d
he's just Gianna oh Gianna Michael
Gianna Michaels yeah okay yeah the
general old school right yeah his old
school two thousands like 2010.
yeah it was it was uh it was Jana
Michaels who's retired now
and it's kind of
you could sell it's her but she's lost
her she's lost it
she's lost it
you like the old school [__]
I like that
2005 to like
or maybe 2000 to 2015
um era was pretty good
um
fashion was good I liked um
the models that they had were good I
liked them
they were femi
even though they were tough
I just uh liked how they looked I liked
the fashion too
you know kids show up with [__] bell
bottoms or something in a damn white
belt remember the most white belts yeah
I remember that well where white belt on
with her jeans
just kind of kind of cute you know
I just like I like that look and the
hair from that
period was pretty good
it was kind of simple but it was it
looked good
not a straight hair it's weird because I
kind of feel like growing up in that era
yeah and maybe this is true of every era
I guess but it's like you don't really
because it's all around you and it's
ubiquitous you don't really think
there's any kind of like Trend going on
at the time but then like 20 years later
you see the [__] and you're like oh my
God yeah there's like everybody right
well it's like well the weird thing
about it is that during the 80s like I
you know I grew up in the 80s you know I
was a teenager in the 80s I was going to
high school
and I was very aware that there was an
80s look that there was an 80s style you
know what I mean like I could have
picked out blah blah and same thing with
the 90s but then like the 2000s came
along and maybe because I was older or
something like that I was just like wow
it just seems like there's not really
any kind of like identifiable style
um I didn't really notice it at the time
I think because of the internet and like
everybody was kind of going off in their
own little subcultures so maybe there
was no like overarching
look you know what I mean but then like
if you look back at movies that were
made in the 2000s
um it's pretty obvious like what the
look was yeah but I guess like you
didn't really know at the time but like
I said in the 80s and 90s I was pretty
even at the time that it was going on I
was just kind of like oh my God like you
it was like pretty easy to see like with
the overarching style was but I think
like once the 2000s came along I kind of
lost track of it you know what I mean
yeah but like later on like when I watch
it
like now when like when we watched um
freeway the other day yeah which came
out in what like 2000 whatever it was
yeah and I was just kind of like oh my
God not so much the clothing but it was
more like the font for the credits and
like the music and everything like that
I'm like oh my God this is like so 2000s
but it's like but I wouldn't have
thought that at the time because it
didn't seem I like I liked freeway I was
um I was impressed by the the fashion
yeah what she was wearing I thought it
was cute but I also liked um the fashion
from um
um
Ginger Snaps Ginger Snaps yeah well that
was that came out the first gender snaps
was 2000. yeah the ones from 2000 I I
liked I liked the fashion a lot and her
little werewolf outfit man I thought
that was hot as [__] it was gray
remember she had like yeah yeah her hair
yeah and it was like a it was like a
knit
um long
jacket sweater yeah and
um the boots that she had
in the pants and everything like I just
thought that and the way her hair was
just kind of uh
it was part in the middle with long it
was like she had blow-dried it or
[__] something it was kind of
just just the way it looked it looked
good
look like a Mane yeah yeah I just
it just it kind of reminded me just
Mississippi during that time you know uh
my first wife and all her friends and
everything they kind of looked like that
and they kind of acted like that
yeah so just I just remember those times
that was
switchblade Symphony time
yeah and switchblade Symphony was still
real big you know and
Prodigy just came out that you know
around that time and yeah looking
Massive Attack they listened to Massive
Attack yeah that's a great band I
remember yeah I report his head from
teleported that out yeah and uh we were
listening to Death in June and stuff
and uh Death in June cover cover albums
and [__]
and um you know drinking chai tea over
at [__] Melissa's house she lived in
a dab witch's Cottage yeah yeah
she's feeding me [__]
Curry
tuna fish sandwiches it's really good
you may you've made me that before yeah
you got to use spice she shot she showed
me how to make it yeah it was that's
good yeah a couple cans of tuna Spice
Islands [__] Curry It's gotta be
Spice Islands that brand
um walnuts and
um [__] diced up green apples green
apples yeah yeah and it had onions and
it had sauteed onions [__] diced up
yeah yeah that's [__] great man
delicious yeah like I said you made that
for me a bunch yeah
and I've eaten now that sandwiches yeah
and it and uh oh and it's um
a 50 50 mixture of mayonnaise and sour
cream yeah that's it that's [__] girl
uh funnily enough we actually watched
the sequel to Ginger Snaps last night
which is on shutter it was good
it's a weird movie though I had
forgotten how weird it was yeah and the
little girl it turns out the little girl
I don't know how little she actually was
I think she was older than she she
seemed to be
she was the villain she was crazy and
you thought she was you thought she was
going to be a good guy yeah well she was
a good guy but she wasn't good through
the whole thing but then she turned out
to be like a [__] secretary which I
thought was kind of interesting I forgot
well like I said the third one they
don't go farther with that because the
third one is like a prequel because that
was the thing I think that what happened
with the sequel I don't know if this is
true or not but what seemed to happen
with a sequel is that they're like at
the end of Ginger Snaps
um you know the the hotter girl Ginger
uh you know she dies spoiler alert so
it's like well we need to make a sequel
but can't really bring her back because
she's dead
so they did a thing where they focus
mainly on the other sister Bridget but
they brought Ginger back as like a ghost
she wasn't exactly a ghost but she was
just kind of like there like giving
advice to the other sister you know what
I mean because they wanted to put her in
the movie because she was like a big
draw I guess but they couldn't justify
putting her in the movie because she
died in the first one so but I think the
third one if I remember correctly is a
prequel like a like a real prequel
because it's going back like hundreds of
years like these are like these are um
like the ancestors of the modern day
like it's set in the [__] 1700s or
1800s they're actually talking about
late 90s early 2000s fashion so it
really says
yeah 2000 fashion has been kind of
making a comeback and I don't like it
[__] back then was so ugly who'd have
thought bedazzling would ever be a thing
again oh God I remember I don't remember
no idea the sparkly things yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's all over all over she
and stuff what about vajazzling where
people were like putting stuff on their
vaginas putting putting rhinestones I
think probably only five people did that
but because it was so weird like they
blew it up into like like it was a thing
he mentioned though that they had yeah
double denim midriffs thongs and lots of
outfits with the brand name all over
them especially track seats oh yeah this
I didn't like that either yeah there was
some like depending on who it was you're
talking about yeah yeah if they if if
in that period cool goth girls [__]
dressed well they they Dre they dressed
there was some cool uh yeah there was
some cool fashion in the right various
but you're right they wore Hip Huggers
they're like Hip Huggers they were
slightly Bell bottomed they weren't as
Bell bottomed as the ones you could get
from seeing right now and yeah they wore
uh thongs
thog underwear with the straps pulled up
so you could see them so you could see
that they were and then it had run a
trap staff on the back yeah so you knew
what oh you was [__] okay but that's
she was sexy as [__] and then in the
front because they were wearing midriff
shirts a [__] pierced [__] belly
belly button I was just looking just
ubiquitous amongst hotties
and uh yeah midriff shirts and ship
I thought it was hot yeah
I was you know late 20s
yeah those girls were all on the menu
you know what I mean man
and if they went to Raves they were like
gravers they were like rave girls the
gothic rave girls they were [__] good
too [__] slots well they would wear
those tiny tiny shirts you had to be
super skinny yeah to even like if you're
fat
yeah so they were like the tiny tiny
midriff shirt like half shirts yeah and
then the belly button ring and then the
huge Janko pants yeah it's a skirt man
but really which like I said it looks so
and then there's like stupid big
platform shoes like sometimes they were
like the big platform tennis shoes which
I [__] hate those but you know what I
mean Tom likes them but I don't like
them but um I like other platforms like
I like platform boots and [__] but
there's like oh let's make tennis shoes
but they look like platforms I think
those are so ugly I like them but um if
they're high-heeled tennis shoe I
thought it looks really good I don't
like anything it looks like all stars
but they got high heels on them I don't
like any kind of tennis shoes like the
only ones I like are like the converse
All-Stars but only like the cut the
classic Converse All-Stars I don't like
any of that kind of like platform
[__] or any of that kind of stuff
it's just I don't like that and I think
it's ugly but um so yeah so
the girl it did look cute like wearing
that but like I said you had to be super
super super young and super super skinny
with implants
right with big tits like to wear that
like anybody else it just didn't look
good yeah my my
first wife and her sister my
sister-in-law were that they were skinny
both had implants and they wore they
dressed like that
more my sister-in-law though than um
than my ex-wife well my ex-wife had
Graver
style stuff that she would wear
sometimes
and both of them were smoking hot
her sister my sister-in-law was like the
top
stripper in Biloxi Mississippi that were
like with their best strip club that
they had there
she [__] pulled down so much [__]
money wasn't even funny especially for a
Mississippi economy
you know and back in those days you know
it was because she her Club was right
outside one of the casinos I think it
was Harris
I think it was Harris either that or
[__] Pirate Bay one of the two
and um
so out of state gamblers would come in
there and she'd clean them out
I got a picture of her I'll show her
[__] um somewhere I think I think I
might have it on this one
her and her my wife and her sister and
she uh
she was easy
two grand twenty five hundred dollars a
week which in Mississippi that's a
fortune
but yeah that's a fortune yeah
let's see if I show her
High Desert says who popularized all
that nonsense it just happened well like
I said that's kind of the shitty thing
is that
it looked cool on like maybe two percent
of people like everybody else that
really didn't look good on them
honestly if you're like uh you know if
you're a girl and you're in your 20s and
cute and skinny you can wear pretty much
anything and it'll look good the rest of
us you know you kind of have to
work around it
you can't just like wear anything you
have to be like well that looks good on
other people but not on me so much you
know what I mean
uh Tom it has been 20 minutes that's
right okay good thank you Tammy thank
you because I probably would have
forgotten I just gotta go release the
pressure go release the prayer don't let
it blow up don't blow up this phone
doesn't have it I'll pick up the other
phone don't blow up the house
Zach says also trucker hats with
rhinestones oh my God
for this big [__] puffy trucker hat
what the [__] was that all about that
was a thing for a minute ugh
I mean I don't really like I don't like
baseball caps
anyway
um especially those douche Bros that
like would wear them backwards all the
time and people still [__] do that so
but yeah because for a time they had
like this puffy trucker hats and that
was kind of like a hipster ironic thing
to be wearing and I'm just kind of like
no it just looks stupid but okay
um yeah giant sunglasses and super
glittery makeup yep that was a thing too
yeah Zach said I remember Paris Hilton
was the big influencer back then
remember the ugly ass designer dog in
your giant purse became a fashion thing
I wonder how that dog felt about that
whole thing it's like just being a
little fashion accessory
I just feel bad for the animals I feel
bad for the animals that's all she's
like I don't want to ride around in your
[__] purse [__]
with all this [__] Ryan Stills and
[__] on it
yeah Hugo said it's time I really
appreciate you guys saying that because
I probably would have forgotten I mean I
maybe wouldn't have but I looked down
and I was just like oh yeah [__] 20
minutes
that's how that goes
yeah I um
I remember bedazzling
see I don't know if I ever saw anybody
with bedazzled [__] on
I remember seeing and maybe I don't even
remember when this was the 90s
like the um
the whole uh what do you call it
what do you call those things the
infomercial the information where they
have that bedazzler thing and they're
just like hey Liz here's your denim
jacket like put all the [__]
rhinestones on that [__]
um you know
that'll be cool as [__] and it was just
seemed so
I don't know it seemed like one of those
things that like you know people
wouldn't [__] Backwater towns would
be like man this looks so cool you know
what I mean that's what my grandma would
make something your grandma would make
it should know why you weren't not
wearing it to school
why don't you ever wear that thing
tonight
[Laughter]
oh my God yeah why didn't why don't you
ever wear that sweater I needed yeah
um because it's lame grandma that's why
yeah I mean you know I know you can't
tell them I know you mean well and
everything well that's what I mean it's
like you can't tell them because then
yeah suddenly you're the [__] but
it's just kind of like they don't know
you're 16 17 year old 17 years old your
grandma buys you some [__] jeans and
they're the [__] worst [__] cut and
they're like tough skins or some [__]
they should make a law where it's like
your elderly relatives should not be
allowed to like buy you clothing yeah
they don't know anything because then
then your parents feel I was like well
you gotta wear it because it's like she
spent money on it or she knitted it or
whatever it's like yo but Mom everyone's
gonna somebody's gonna beat me up
it's that kind of [__] you know that was
Lindsay
that was Lindsay
and that was that's
okay and see if I can
she she had a baby she lived with us for
a little while
and that that was that's what she looked
like
she made so much [__] money
Zach says Owen wearing a short sleeve
over a long sleeve shirt was a thing for
guys in the 2ks yeah I remember that too
um I had a single shirt as a kid that
was designed to look like that yeah I
think I might have had a couple like
that too that was a very big thing
um yeah you wore like a long sleeve
shirt and then like a t-shirt over it so
then after a while they started making
like a one-piece thing that would look
like
it was like an elite optical illusion
you know I'll say the one with the beret
there they are the one with the Beret is
my first wife Tiff
and then that's Lindsay which he had
long hair next to her
that's that's just what they were
[__] like they didn't [__] hammer
it up for the photo they were fun though
you guys said how about this red
Popeye's boots
uh size boots wait I don't remember
those
I mean I kind of remember those but not
exactly
my brain's kind of like going
trying to like focus in on it
but I do remember the long the long
sleeve under the short sleeve I remember
that
but I'm trying to think of like because
like I said I think after the 19 the mid
1990s I kind of stopped caring I mean I
didn't really care at all that much
before to be honest with you but like
after the mid-2000s I was like I don't
really give a [__] about this Normie
[__] anymore so I was just kind of like
I didn't really pay attention so maybe
that's why
maybe that's why I don't I never really
got a sense of
2000's fashion until now I look look
back at movies that came back out back
then and I was just not like oh yeah
like I could tell when that came out
because I wasn't really paying attention
to it I guess at the time
but
Zach said all I think of when I think of
the 90s was what's her name's haircut
from friends and brown lipstick yeah
yeah I remember that yeah Jennifer
Anderson Jennifer Anderson everybody had
that well I didn't have that but a lot
of people had that [__] haircut he
talked about the brown lipstick the girl
I was dating at the time her name was
Lisa and she she was a hairdresser is
that in Boston
and she had she had a reddish brown
lipstick that was super [__] in style
back then it was called vamp yeah yeah I
remember that it came with it was it was
it was [__] lipstick with matching
nail polish that's what she wore yeah I
remember that yeah
I never got into the brown though I
remember when it was real big but I was
always like a bright red girl or black
or dark red or dark purple
like that was pretty much yeah I don't
do nude colors I don't do brown I don't
do
any of those and I don't like shiny
lipstick either not a glossy girl I like
matte you know yeah
um so and that's probably until I die
I'm just I don't like shiny lips I just
don't
so and so I don't know
I don't know what to tell you
that's just my whole aesthetic
they're talking about Paris Hilton like
the dog yeah she used to carry around
and high desert said I hope that dog
[__] in her purse regularly yeah it
probably pissed in there it probably she
probably had a damn town she probably
had like a little like a little doggy
diaper yeah probably a towel like a
little pee towel they have those you
know that you can like put underneath
the dogs
like if you if you have dogs that have
like
I wonder if she actually cared about
that dog or she just took it around so
she can see I I feel like probably not
yeah I mean to me like I said it just
seemed like a fashion accessory I'm like
that's that's a that's a sentient animal
can we not I'm not sure why was sentient
does it yes how is how is a Chihuahua
any different than pookie
you wouldn't carry Pookie around in a
person like expected like look at my
fashion accessory I would never do that
to her she would be like super stressed
out
she's like my kid I wouldn't do that so
it's like and you wouldn't carry your
kid around in a purse you know what I
mean and like happens like look at the
paparazzi look I have a cute kid in my
purse that's [__] up you wouldn't do
that so don't do it to an animal either
I'm just saying but it's like I don't
know
I don't know what that whole [__]
thing is about I don't like that whole
basic [__] thing you know
and Mom G's were a nice thing too yeah
but yeah I think that was like a yeah
that was a 90s thing God man what was
that all about that made every single
but even if you were skinny if you wore
those jeans they've legit made you look
like a you had a potbelly so they either
made you look pregnant or
like you had a beer belly as they were
just not flattering on anybody and they
also were kind of high-waisted so they
made your ass look flat
so I'm not really sure why anybody
although
I will say that in the 80s
um they had those horrible genes which
the acid wash I [__] hated those even
back in the 80s I think I had one pair
that somebody gave me and it's like they
were so ugly I didn't like them
um and they were like
they had like the tight waist and then
it was kind of like the the waist would
come out and then there was like Pockets
so it always made your hips and ass look
like wider than you wanted them to and
then like the legs would go down to
peg legs so it's like it made everybody
look like a [__] ice cream cone what
was that all about think about not
flattering at all
those beans some of them are kind of a
little bit
firm
I might pressure cook them more some
more they're sitting in that hot water
though
I mean it's up you know how what what
the deal is so I don't know it's all up
to you Tom I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
put them in for like another I'm gonna
I'm gonna
High Desert said I don't remember too
much of the 2000s I was sort of in a
cult then oh well do tell were you for
real like legitimately in a cult
because I would like to hear about that
Zach said as far as I'm concerned the
best part of the 90s fashion was
anything Fran Drescher wore on the nanny
because God that [__] is still stylish
yeah she actually did look good on that
[__] you could still wear that nowadays
and get away with that
uh I thought of them as thrift store
jeans they were just so
you can't wear anything that's like that
where the waist is at that point and
it's just like and there was just so
much room in the jeans so it looked like
even if you didn't have a pot belly it
made you look like you had a pot belly
I don't really get
one thing I will say for the 70s as
horrifying as some of the fashion was
from the 70s at least they called the
[__] with
like kind of the lower slung like hip
hugger stuff with kind of like a bell
bottom not massive bell bottoms but a
little bit of a bell bottom is actually
good that's actually flattering it makes
your thighs look smaller
um you know what I mean like the the hip
hugger's the thing it's like as long as
you don't have like a huge muffin top or
anything like that it actually makes
your ass look better so the [__] that
was going on in the 80s and 90s I don't
know what that was about I don't I don't
know whose idea that was but it's like
that looked good on precisely
0.05 percent of the population everybody
else that looked really really bad on I
thought
I thought it was just really
unflattering
really unflattering
I still don't know what the what the
Popeyes boots thing is
oh High Desert said I was living in
Japan then it was a type of Buddhist
group but I didn't get it late
okay
okay so you did kind of like Miss I
don't know that's enough you didn't miss
much of anything
um you know
uh
I don't know like I said I kind of
checked out
of
mainstream culture in 1994
over thereabouts 1992 1994 somewhere
around there and um didn't really pay
attention to it anymore so I kind of get
chip filtered in every now and then but
most of the time I don't know what's
going on I don't know what's going on
I'll put them in for another 15 minutes
it smells good anyway I can smell it
I was talking about those 80s jeans
remember those 80s jeans that were kind
of like that had like the pockets and
[__] and like made there was like all
this space in here and it made your like
[__] yeah hips and [__] look enormous
and then it was like Peg Leg so like I
said it made everybody look like an ice
cream cone yeah like everything well in
the 80s everybody wanted to look
triangular for some reason yeah I don't
know what they were thinking like it's
like oh we want these big like shoulder
pads yeah because that makes you if your
shoulders look wider than that makes
your waist look smaller I think that was
what the thinking behind it was but I
was like it just makes everybody look
like this
which
not not so much sure Max Headroom came
from
yeah every everything was like
triangular
I and I'm not
humans are not triangular shaped
it just was it wasn't flying it wasn't
flying
and it's funny because every now and
then and especially if you watch
um Dan Bell like he'll like some of his
older [__] like when he'll edit in into
his dead Mall videos he'll edit in like
old infomercials and like just old
commercials and stuff like from the
1980s like old-fashioned shows and stuff
and it's like man some of the fashion
from back in the 80s and even back then
like I was just kind of like holy [__]
that [__] is so ugly because
who the [__] would look at even the
models didn't look good in that [__]
like it's like like that's a big huge
[__] sweater dresses and it's just
like it just made everybody look really
dumpy
you know it just it wasn't fitted it
wasn't
I don't know everybody just looked like
a [__] potato sack I don't know what
that was all about
somebody had a good laugh at that at all
of those models expense look at these
people behind this ugly ass [__]
everybody's walking around looking like
a [__] sack of oatmeal
I don't know what that was all about I
don't know
uh yeah High Desert says it's hard to
find good thrift store Couture that
isn't super skinny oh thank you or extra
extra large
I had that problem too when I was
thrifting in my teens and 20s
a lot of clothes that came from
you know 20s 30s 40s uh the sizing was a
lot smaller because people were a lot
smaller back then because you know now
everybody's fat but back then everybody
was like really really small so it was
like really really hard to find anything
that fit because everything was like
super small
Zach said or the 80s look where it was
trendy to be 30 but dressed like your
grandma
yeah everything everything just looked
real dumpy
you know like all the pants were like
high-waisted and poofy like right in the
midsection they were pleated like yeah
yeah stupid way which yeah which just
that poofs out it just it makes you look
like you have like amazing it makes you
look pregnant is what it looks like
there's something good on a model
Maybe
but then they were handing it out at the
[__] to the General Public
selling that [__] out of JC Penney's
and yeah people weren't as obese back
then but they still weren't in real good
shape well it's still it's just not even
like skinny people didn't look real good
in it yeah they're not gonna lie
it just looked real
because I was watching what was I
watching the other day
the original Nightmare on Elm Street
from 1984.
and
uh Heather langenkamp in that at one
point wears an outfit that's like
80s like high-waisted pleated pants I
think were they brown or tan or
something
and then she had like this pinkish like
blouse and then there's like a sweater
vest over it but that only came to here
yeah and she's like a cute girl and
she's not fat or anything like that but
it's like that outfit made her look
super yeah frumpy yeah like a lot of
that stuff looked really really frumpy
so
I don't know what everybody was thinking
I don't know and I don't get the whole
sweater dress thing either I had a
couple of those because people gave them
but
there's really really looks bad
Zach says what I do like is that
hippie-ish thrift store Earth Tone type
look from the 70s that [__] looks easy
and comfy that's back it's called fairy
core
yeah it looks better now than it did
yeah well because like I said there was
some good [__] in the 70s yeah
yeah but a lot of the stuff from the 70s
was pretty ugly
in the 90s
fairy core that what you're talking
about reappeared as what we would call
now is fairy core a lot of the those
Grudge
female
um [__] rock stars were wearing stuff
like that it was
earth tones
kind of bell-bottom Hip Huggers
um blonde hair you know kind of
I don't know who dressed like that who'd
be a good a good good I'm trying to
think like who looked like that back in
the day
um
now I can't think I didn't want to say
uh
cranberries a little no not cranberries
what was uh
I guess it doesn't really matter but you
you would see that it was almost kind of
like a cleaned up
sexier version of Something That Jazz
Joplin would have worn
they might have even had kind of like
blonde dreads and stuff they kind of
look like yeah I remember that well
because the thing about it was that
front like if if you weren't around back
then like the end of the 80s and the
early 90s there was a big 60s and 70s
throwback yeah
um because I remember I was in high
school from 88 89 90 because I graduated
in 1990.
and there was a whole big contingent of
kids in my school that were into the
doors and Led Zeppelin and stuff like
that and wore like and Grateful Dead and
like War like hippie [__] like that yeah
you know what I mean
um so that was it was just kind of like
you know how the beginning of the 80s it
was like a big 50s throwback so there
was kind of like a small contingent of
people that were kind of like looked
like greasers yeah so it was that kind
of whole thing
um
it was kind of the same thing in the
late 80s and early 90s there was a big
hippie Resurgence where people were
listening to [__] from the 60s and 80s
and dressing like the 60s and 70s and
it's come back now as fairy core yeah it
looks well I will say that it looks
better it looks better than it did back
then what it is fairy core is kind of
like
did
you take goth cuts and Goth pieces of
goth clothing
you change the colors and the materials
to earth tones like
OD greens
uh Browns uh like autism kind of colors
right it might have a little bit of like
burnt orange you're right then you
replace bats
with [__] butterflies moths and
mushrooms and yeah and skulls are
replaced with mushrooms
and but it's basically the same cuts and
and it's similar boots
but instead of being black boots
they're going to be like tan or brown
suede
it looks good it looks real good I like
it yeah we have a cup I have bought a
couple of dresses like that
I have a couple
um I have a dress that's like
I guess it's sort of like I don't want
to say olive green but it's almost kind
of like a like a toned down dark
teal-ish green
and it has kind of like moths all over
it yeah and then I also have one that's
like a dark Rose
that has like um kinda
flowers on it but they're subdued it's
very subdued looking but it's a nice Cut
and it's got like kind of some dark red
lace like around the outside around the
top
neckline
but I do like some of the stuff in there
some of it I don't like but some of it
actually is really nice actually Tom
just ordered me some
pants some bell bottoms yeah that are
kind of like patchworky but like I said
they're like Autumn sort of colors like
dark orange and dark red and
dark brown and they're cool looking
man I still have that pair of pants that
you bother me it has the the comic book
kind of stuff with like the The Woman
kissing the skeleton or whatever I still
haven't worn those yet
I have worn like the other pants you got
me the hats go that had like dancing
skeletons and [__] on them yeah actually
I wore this one that one pair to
fairy core looks like that
I have a dress very similar to that yeah
the skirt's different but it's the same
color
yeah High Desert said I remember going
to a Tori Amos show people were dressed
like that yeah it was it was very much a
thing like in the 90s like it's with
like Lilith Fair like all that kind of
stuff like Sarah McLaughlin and the
Indigo Girls and like all the people
that were into that kind of stuff
um it was kind of a throwback to hippie
stuff but with a 90s sensibility to it I
guess everybody had like chokers and
everything was kind of like subdued
colors and I get that but that's that's
coming back like in a big way apparently
and I have we have bought like some
outfits like that
they don't love that that looks a little
looks a little too red centered well
it's a little much it's a little busy
but some of it looks really good but
some of it's cool yeah because I have
bought some dresses from that collection
that I actually read kind of like the
the more brown stuff this is kind of
like the goth version of [__] fairy
well and you bought me one that's sort
of like that but short right and it's a
little bit like it's not that exact
color but it's similar
like it's kind of like a modeled
Brown kind of color but but the one I
have is short
not long
but I do like some of that stuff
Tom's trying to get me to like wear
colors yeah
I'm kind of resistant but you know what
I mean stuff like that I like some
colors but
sometimes you can have too much colors
you know
too much colors
but I'm willing to
I'm willing to go a little way toward
that because I know you like colors
that's pretty much a goth outfit but
that's just they just change the colors
and the materials around well and like I
said you can have a dress like that but
you can put all of the kind of gothy
yeah accessories with it yeah like if
you wear that with boots or like a
little black shrug or something like
that like I don't think anybody would
look as gants you know
see again that's a little much I like it
that's a little much it's almost kind of
like
what's her name
talk to the hand talk to the hand
did you order me that dress no see
Adam's got skulls on it
we looked at that one yeah we just
didn't order it
High Desert said someone should open a
clothing store called frumpy fashions
the sad thing is probably some people
would shop there
they probably would
I don't know why people want to look
frumpy but
I mean I can see like buying an outfit
and like not realizing that you look
frumpy or
you know just being well I like it I
don't really care that's fine but
in the 80s I kind of feel like
everybody's wearing that [__] and it
just looked bad on everybody that's
super
I like her hair very core see it says
right there very cool
I think like the pants that you got me
there was also another option that had
that same that was made of that same
family but that's not the ones
Zach says I'm still kind of mad my hair
wasn't long enough to get in on the man
bun Trend back in 2013.
some people look good with the man bun
you know I don't I don't I I know a lot
of people [__] on the man but I don't
mind it
I didn't mind it
especially if you had like the man bun
and then like you had like the long
beard and stuff too because it was kind
of like evened out you know what I mean
I don't know
depending like I said depending on the
person some people can wear it some
people not just like everything else
just like everything else
Hi Desert said my mom would drag me to
JC Penney's on the weekend and spend
hours trying to find something to wear
yeah that's the thing
um my grandma used to have it you know a
long time ago when I was a kid she had a
JCPenney credit card so a lot of times
she would take me like shopping for the
yeah he got me those pants that's the
pants I got her
I think they're gonna look good yeah
we'll see and those are fairy core pants
yeah yeah
because like I said they kind of remind
me of um yeah
Sally from Nightmare Before Christmas
yeah with the patch working yeah that
cut of pants tends to look good on me
yeah she looks good in bell bottoms
the pants I have on right here are bell
bottoms
time also buy me these ones but these
ones are black these are the good with
black yes black and gray and stuff yeah
I mean you wear some black platform
boots with that like you wear like a
black shirt with it like you have black
hair it would be cool you know
uh Zach said I remember those scented
oils for your beard were a big thing too
that's an oil for your beard yeah I kind
of yeah I remember that and then the
Great Gatsby with DiCaprio came out in
the 20s became big again yeah that's
right although I kind of wish
that the 20s had been more of a bigger
thing because I don't remember seeing
people walk around like flapper [__]
which would have been [__] awesome
because I love that look but like I said
again
the flapper look really only works if
you're super skinny
and flat chested and flat chested yeah I
mean to be fair big boob girls don't
look good in the flapper [__] you kind
of have to be
straight up and down it looks good then
but
oh they said back then the idea was to
look like a boy basically
it'd be built like a boy
well yeah well I like I said the 1920s
was kind of they were sort of yeah
they're like we're gonna start smoking
cigarettes like boys do and we're kind
of trying to look like boys and they
we're gonna go out dance and we're gonna
do the same [__] that boys do yeah
people don't realize it's 19 that they
think the sexual Revolution they think
of boot Baby Boomers no
1920s and then there were some of them
well there are sexual revolutions every
[__] 40 or 50 years is one of
and uh the 20s was wild it was yeah and
they had lesbian clubs gay clubs uh
lesbianism was a big [__] thing
especially in Europe like girls would go
to Europe to go to the lesbian clubs and
they would just dress up as
some of them dress up as men and some of
them would dress up as women and they
would just as they would call drag Kings
yeah drag Kings yeah so
and uh
they had the flappers were kind of what
you would call nowadays you'd call that
gender non-binary is what they would
call well yeah they were trying to be
like kind of asexual yeah well and like
I said because the time in the 1920s it
was kind of scandalous for women to
smoke
um for women to go out to nightclubs and
swear yeah and drink a lot yeah that was
very scandalous yeah so like the in the
1920s that was kind of women being like
[__] it we're gonna go out and have fun
just like the dudes do and then he would
wear pants yeah which was a big actually
my grandmother who was born in 1929 so
you know what I mean so she was like
when she was growing up it was a bit
like if she if you wore pants that was
kind of like people would like look all
weird at you and that wasn't even that
long ago right you know there were a lot
of rich girls started wearing pants and
doing things like flying airplanes and
driving cars
and people were just catalyzed that was
considered to be yeah girls don't do
that kind of stuff and and what the [__]
that they would say too you know uh was
wild they weren't they weren't just
bullshitting
nowadays you would they were kind of
like gender fluid because they would say
things like oh yeah well you know these
men aren't all that I could date a woman
too they would say that kind of stuff
yeah and people would be like they'd be
like yeah and they made it they were
doing that and um
also interracial stuff was [__] a lot
more common than people think it was
especially you started like yeah that
was that was pretty big in the 20s yeah
um
May West only dated black guys
you know and she was kind of open about
it it's just uh the Press worded it a
certain way
she was with her handsome muscular
driver
and she's like yeah when I escorted by
her her bodyguard
and or being escorted by a uh uh her
strong handsome bought professional
boxer friend and these are all black
guys
she was in a big strong [__] black
dudes that's that's what she liked she
was she was a [__] too man she was
[__] funny
real smart real small she's the [__]
yeah we should do a show about her
actually she was like super active she
was a size queen
she like big dudes and I don't think she
was very big I think he was little
she was great I mean she was like so
[__] funny man I love [__] Midwest
yeah and they didn't like
put it in your face but all the the
newspapers basically let you know what
to deal with and evidently everybody in
Hollywood knew they were all cool with
it cool people didn't give a [__] about
that
well I think that's always the case yeah
like most of the time people are just
kind of like yeah you do you whatever
hon but it's just kind of like you know
other people other people are
scandalizing it was the plebes yeah it
was the plebs that we get scandalized oh
my God we can't watch any more of her
small town people we're gonna have to
cancel her
exactly the small towns were dominated
by Churches
and the local church the local churches
[__] told them what to think and they
were probably like the worst [__]
that's probably all kinds of abuse going
on in there yeah like I said at least
like at least people that were doing
that were like being pretty much open
about it
well the South you know I know the
history of the South pretty well the
South was just totally dominated by your
local church and the local church was
kind of like the local Club
and uh [__] um but there's this
Outsider perception that the South was
somehow uptight and Pious no it was
[__]
wow even back right but the thing about
it was that they tried to keep you had a
public face right
and I don't like that I don't like look
if you're gonna be like all [__]
perverted and [__] like that at least be
open about it yeah don't try to pretend
that you're all upstanding and like
looking down your nose at other people
oh look at that horror or whatever when
you're doing worship than them just
pretending Mexico central
you know I grew up in Brazil partial
part of town
Central and South American culture is
exactly the same way they're family
oriented they're very they honor their
own traditions and part of that is
religion but they go there to kind of do
the correct thing it's like a ritual but
then as soon as that's over they do
whatever the [__] they want we'll see
but that's okay that's that's all I mean
I grew up in the South too and I get it
like I you know I know that people are
like that because I grew up around it
but it's like I don't like that I don't
like any kind of fakery I don't like
deception of any kind it's just I don't
like [__]
um if you're as long as you're doing
[__] that like I said everyone's
consenting and everything's fine like I
don't give a [__] what you're doing it
doesn't have anything to do with me and
and I don't really like people that have
to go out of their way
to have this kind of like whole facade
where it's like oh I'm so Pious and I'm
this and that I'm just like [__] that
it's just yeah I don't I don't like that
I don't understand I know exactly what
you're talking about like I'm just I've
Just Seen another Viewpoint of it
in Brazil
it's mostly it's Catholic it's
Catholicism
you go to Catholic Church in the working
class in the lower working class areas
you're going to see people in church and
in the church you're also going to see
the hookers and the [__] hookers in
church taking communion it's just
well yeah I get that they're absolving
themselves their sins they can go out
turn tricks but and everybody knows what
they are everybody knows what they do
for a living that's just part
of the rituals nature of it and you know
so they can be good with themselves and
good be good with the afterlife they
want to go to heaven everybody wants to
go to heaven every you know that that
that's if if they believe that they want
to go to heaven you know that's that's
well I guess I guess it's I guess it's
easier for me because I wasn't I did I
wasn't brought up in any religion
um so it doesn't really hold any
appeal for me it doesn't hold any
special kind of thing for me I don't
really get having to go through this
whole rainbow I don't really get it it
just seems kind of I understand
counterproductive I understand it's just
that religion isn't entiresome religion
isn't for everybody
all right yeah it's definitely not for
me there's a certain kind of person that
they have to have it yeah I get that
yeah but I'm just I'm not that kind of
person there's another kind of person
that wants it but doesn't actually
believe it
it's like I said it's like a ritual or
something yeah yeah I've met some people
like that yeah I'm just saying for me
it's just I don't know if it's just
because that's the kind of person I am
or if it's just I wasn't really raised
like that or
I mean I'm my family were not hostile to
religion um you know most of my family
did say they believed in things and
stuff like that but it's just it wasn't
anything that was a big part of our
lives and
so it never really
it was never really part of my life and
I just never really was interested in
high desert's going oh God don't bring
Bell bottles back I agree bell bottoms
really shouldn't be for guys
but they look great on women
yeah like I was saying actually they
will as long I'm not talking about like
big huge [__] bell bottoms some of
those that look cool too it depends
depends on what it is
but I have like the pants I have on that
right now are slightly bell bottoms yeah
but like I said they actually these are
very very flattering like I said they
make your they make your thighs look
smaller make your thighs look good your
ass look real good yeah and they're kind
of low kind of hip hugger because they
kind of they kind of give you that kind
of [__] yeah like I said the the [__] in
the 80s made you look like a ice cream
cone you make you look like triangular
which is not flattering on anybody and I
actually we were looking on Sheehan the
other night
and they had some pants like that they
were like real tight but were like Peg
legged yeah and even the skinny girls
wearing that [__] looked fat to me yeah
peg legs make they look like they had
they look like fat and short-legged yeah
um even if they were thin that friend
Jan you used to have remember the
heavyweight the heavy one I think her
name was Jed wasn't it she would make
all the mistakes at the same time peg
leg pants she was fat peg leg pants and
then those little bitty high-heeled
stiletto without a
platform on them at all remember that
yeah they're pointed
and then you just it looked like you got
a little [__] little pig hoof
stick it out
why would she dress like that
I don't know and she'd wear that zero
today remember yeah yeah it was a trip
and she'd walk around and you just hear
the damn heels scratching against the
ground
yeah
we'd be driving in the car and [__] [__]
it should be in the back seat [__]
trying to flash her titties at me
yeah she's telling you don't date him
don't date that guy yeah she warned me
though yeah she wanted it I think she
even did a background check on you yeah
she don't date that dude he's he's with
I didn't know that she's in the
background check I'm not saying that
yeah I told her yeah she did that
without mine there's nothing there it's
like is she
excuse don't say dead dude he's bad he's
dangerous and then she's trying to
[__] [__] me
was trying to [__] you over
yeah I know yes yeah
I know yeah yeah well she wasn't really
your friend though I mean well I'd known
her since high school yeah to be honest
oh okay but um well now I'm just saying
that
it was kind of uh yeah it was kind of
obvious that
she kept warning me about you yeah but
then every time we would go somewhere
together like with you she was like
hardcore like flirting with you yeah
yeah
so it she probably is justifying it like
well I'll show her that he's a hoe and
I'll get you know what I mean [__]
I'll get him to do something but I was
like look at her going
[Laughter]
no oh no
yeah Tom never took that Pete
then that
you had she had dudes gunning for her
that [__] wanted to kill me
remember those short fat dude who rode
the motorcycles
he had the beard you didn't like the guy
wait a minute what time period are we
talking about back when you lived in
your apartment
a little short fat guy oh oh oh okay
sorry I just remember couldn't get rid
of me kept coming around coming around
coming around
he had a friend he had a friend who was
transsexual riding a [__] sport bike
remember that yeah yeah I had forgotten
until you said something I remember him
yeah I'm not gonna say that and that
dude would [__] lie and say all kinds
of [__] about him
he said he was gonna kill me
I don't remember that but I'm not I'm
not saying I don't believe you I'm just
saying yeah yeah
but maybe he did he's not that one of
these days I'd like to kill you
did he really say that yeah oh just
kidding you know
like I was looking at this dude like
dude I'd [__] smash you even back
then I would have smash that dude yeah
and you weren't even jacked back then
that wasn't even Jack back then I was
smashed that dude what was that all
about he was [__] jealous he was
[__] gutter for you
yeah that was kind of that was like my
Prime I had like all these dudes like
yeah and Rob was after you the same time
yeah I remember that yeah
kept inviting you to that restaurant and
I'd go with you every time and I'd see
him [__] see me you go God damn it
anymore
I can't get rid of me come on
yeah you were always around and I knew
it was well the thing about it was that
I don't even think we were like
officially going out of time yeah we're
just buddies but I was just kind of like
come with me yeah
I don't want this to look like [__] yeah
I don't want him to get any weird ideas
right well yeah that's what I mean but
she was getting weird idea I mean I had
like I said that was probably like my
Prime hotness period because I was just
kind of like well I don't know about
that like I feel like maybe you're not
just young yeah well younger yeah I was
I was so old I was 38 39. yeah that was
for uh for our crap yeah that's pretty
it looked a lot younger than that right
so I did have a lot of
um hangers on let's call it that and at
least one kind of stalker yeah so there
was that going on too it wasn't like a
bad it wasn't bad bad but it was kind of
like 200 texts a day kind of
but nobody like no I'm like showing up
there's a gym back in those days it
wasn't like that but and I never thought
he was gonna kill me or nothing but it
was just kind of like he was just trying
he was just persistent yeah persistent
that's all it was so um
and this was yeah right they were nice
though yeah yeah well honestly like um
like almost all of them were nice yeah I
never had anybody
that
um
like that I thought was gonna like oh
[__] I'm in danger from this person
which I'm lucky because I know that's
I'm just mentioned into bad words a lot
of chicks don't have that yeah because
look I I was friends with a girl who had
that situation and it got bad like in
the sense that I had to go with her to
the cops and file a restraining order
I'm talking about like I'm sending you
text saying I'm gonna kill you I'm
turning up at your workplace and like
just staring at you like that kind of
[__] so you know what I mean I never had
anything that bad but
you know
um
we've all been there yeah the time Jen
is talking about
were these days
actually before these days actually yeah
that's probably earlier than yeah
because I remember when that was what
was that there's Angel over there yeah
let me see I'll find some even older
ones
High Desert said what was the worst
fashion faux pas you ever saw
ooh that's a good question
where's fashion faux pas
I see fashion faux pas pretty much all
the time
I can't think of like any particularly
egregious one though
although I could probably think of
something if I had time to think about
it
other than like I don't know people
coming in with like [__] Crocs
I don't know why anybody would wear this
I know they're comfortable well I don't
know they're comfortable I've never worn
them even if they were the most
comfortable shoes in the world then
still don't worry because they're ugly
as [__] ah you know what I mean remember
her oh God we're good we're taking a
trip then oh my God she died yeah yeah
we're talking about this is the time
it's me and Jen this is more around the
time that she was talking about yeah
that's right that's what you're trying
to get hair and yeah let me see if we
can get this thing
come on
what we're talking about is this girl
standing next to us she was a nice girl
man she died died of a brain tumor right
after this photo more or less
yeah it was probably like only a few
months after that yeah they couldn't
they couldn't help her
she was what 29 yeah Young
younger than 29 I think more like yeah
she might have been younger than that
yeah
weird
that was her
she was nice too yeah
Zach said you look basically the same
Jen congrats on fighting yeah finding
the Fountain of you I'm gonna try to
find a room I'm gonna try to find a real
old picture of Jim yeah find a really
old one yeah
Zach says also what about Janet
Jackson's boob falling out on the Super
Bowl
I can't believe everybody flipped out
about that I just can't believe it's a
boob
we've all got them if you've ever seen
the young ones they're called breasts
and we all have them dudes have them too
I don't understand why it's okay for
dudes to show their boobs and it's not
okay for girls to show theirs so
same
here's a roll with a jam let me see
oh
it's a good photo that's pretty old yeah
yeah
it's me and Jen I still have those uh
those hair Falls yeah
yeah this was and they still look uh
2015 so it's not that old
we can go back older than that even
yeah because we got together in what
2011. yeah you think we had older
pictures than that
Tammy said like Eddie Izzard said
there's a thin line between looking cool
and looking like a [__] that's right
it's a it's a circle
looking cool looking cool looking like a
[__] and that's how it goes
I was just thinking about I was just
thinking about Eddie azard the other day
oh I know why because I was looking at I
was on um AV club and they were talking
about like the
best comedy specials of all time and
Eddie is our dress to kill was on there
I'm gonna say I love dress to kill that
was the first one of um of theirs that I
saw but
I think circle is probably my favorite
okay remember this that's ancient okay
that's really old this is an ancient one
that might be from 2011 or 2012. maybe
that was me and Jen
I can't even fit in that job I'm [__]
loaded look at me I'm drunk off yeah
he's super dead yeah yeah you probably
weighed 110 pounds well and that was
before I got the the boob yeah before
implants so I can't get that jacket over
my tits anymore right because that
jacket is very small I think I still
have it but it won't button over my
chest anymore
Hi Desert said you guys looked cute oh
thank you oh
Tammy said he's going to be touring the
US in the front side
I might have to go I just I never got to
I never got to see Eddie Izard and I
would love to see it he is
Tommy look good with that hair
with hair thanks yeah
I think you look good both ways I did
like you with the Black Arrow and you
had white hair for a while like bleach
blonde and that looked cool too here's
another Ancient One
it's a good one what year you think that
is
um that is maybe 2012 2013. I remember
that that was when
that was from venue 13 and that was um
that's actually one of my favorite
pictures of us in the frame look how
good we looked
I actually looked like I [__]
civilized human being you did actually
yeah
wow when did that ever happen again yeah
whatever and the thing is is that I was
not young then I was maybe 41 42. yeah I
was 30 yeah 89 40. yeah around that time
yeah I remember that was when venue 13
was at that not at the Chinese
restaurant but it was at that I don't
even remember what that [__] venue
was
the [__] was that place I think it was
only there for like a two months or
something
I want to find some even older ones
those were not uh we could get older
than that
I mean those are pretty old if you go
back that much farther like it'll be
like before I even met you
yeah so
well there are some of them though
before we were a dig
we were a TIG here
I don't remember what year that was from
come on what the [__]
Focus
Jen looks really cute in it
she almost looks Japanese in it
There She Goes
yeah I remember that picture yeah I
still have that corset too yeah
well that's right
that's the one with the big buckles
right yeah yeah I swallowed that
it might fit now I remember her
she was open about what she did remember
we can say oh right right yeah yeah all
right that oh my God I forgot about yeah
it's been a long time this girl here
next to this I forgot her name we
haven't seen her in a long long time
she was an escort
but she was she was an escort but a goth
yeah
Zach said you look like Timothy Dalton
in that one pick yeah who me yeah yeah
well no me yeah you look like I look
like Timothy Nolton yeah Tom what it's
done yeah yeah that'd be pretty weird if
I looked like Timothy Dalton
yeah this is another Ancient One
oh [__] I remember that we with the
martini yeah
I got cute gymnast look at her face
that was when I had my dyed red hair
yeah that was her real hair and it was
super short yeah yeah I remember that
I don't remember who we were with who
took that picture Tyson
oh that's right yeah that's right yeah
mini me that was uh yeah I forgot I had
forgotten all about that yeah it was a
dude who's just totally [__]
infatuated with me would not shut up
about me oh my God that was a weird
situation yeah we've been through some
weird [__] you guys I forget about it
but it's just like then when you remind
me I'm just kind of like oh yeah he
tried to give me the Chinese girl he
bought
yeah we're
here yeah no [__]
botter and had her set here in a [__]
shipping container
that's what we heard yeah and she was a
school teacher yeah she was all right
yeah she was all right he was he but he
was like look man I can't I can't keep
her anymore he's like you can have her I
told you know you can have her if you
want her I'll give her to you
and I was like wait what what are you
talking about that's a person you know
that right he goes he's like well I
bought her right you know he bought her
bought her from China [__] she she
came here in a shipping container
and I was like dude I I can't take your
[__] Chinese girl he's talking about
a person like he's talking about like an
old sofa yeah anymore yeah you say you
want her anymore she's not want her
anymore
he still got her though
does he yeah you still got her I don't
know well that's a herd oh that was a
long time ago there right yeah a long
time I haven't heard anything but I
didn't think he lived here anymore
somebody told me that they're still
together
who told you but that was a few years
back oh okay maybe five years ago yeah
we haven't heard anything about them in
a long time yeah
lost track of all those people
oh remember that what
oh that was bloodbath yeah
it was a good photo
yeah I like that one too yeah
yeah
that was um I was about better knocked
that's what prior to Memento Mori The
Goth Knight was called mid or not which
means midnight if you didn't know and um
every year they would do a big thing
called the bloodbath yeah and that's
Jen's real hair everybody would be
covered with I cut that hair yeah
and um I guess I'm about 42 there wow
probably 2012. yeah
I think so that's probably like Niners
well 10 11 years ago yeah I think that
was
that was at the old Eye bar yeah
Zach says I look good with short hair
thank you
I don't know it's really short though
well no it was at that time in the not
in that picture but in the in the one
before with the martini oh okay yeah
because remember you cut it yeah right
to the underside of my ears and then I
dyed it red because that's the
that's still my uh driver's license
photo because that's when I had to renew
my driver's license so my driver's
license photo my my hair is like this
short and it's bright red
um but I don't know I feel like every
now and then I'm just kind of like oh my
God this hair is so long and I'm just so
[__] sick of dealing with it then I'm
just gonna cut it super short so I have
Tom cut it super short and then I'm like
why the [__] did I do this now my head
looks like a huge bowling ball
you know what I mean I know but like I
have that same it happens every single
[__] time every time okay look we
just started going out then
oh yeah yeah okay yeah that's a very
early we had just started a very early
Tom and Jen yeah we just started going
out there I think we took that with your
shitty old cell phone yeah that was your
your flip phone yeah and I think that
must have been around 2011. oh does that
sound about right
about 2011. I don't even have that
necklace anymore yeah
that's how long the serious look I got
on my face that's right and then chance
like man she looks like Susie
from Susie and the Banshees
yeah no that we didn't take that with my
cell phone I I took that from with my
laptop
did you yeah in the house yeah I thought
you took that with yourself no I think
we were sitting in in my bedroom
and I I clicked it with the laptop oh
before we went out before we went out
yeah yeah I sent it to a phone
okay that's right that's why it looks
though
High Desert said those pictures remind
me of my club days I feel old now thanks
uh it's okay we're old too
we're all so old I don't know how old
you are high desert but
I'll be 51 in
September
yeah and you just turned 50
54. yeah
so yeah
and we still go into clubs too we still
go to the clubs yep we're thinking about
going tomorrow night yeah
we'll see how it goes
I want to do a Saturday night we haven't
done a Saturday night
at Barbarella I want to go dance to some
80s [__]
that'd be fun
Zach said you could always do a like a
pixie cut type deal I guess but
I don't know I'm always like reluctant
I'm always reluctant because I just
always feel like it's it seems like a
good idea at the time and then like
after I do it I'm just kind of like God
damn it
it looks so bad well maybe it wouldn't
be bothersome now because I have so many
wigs so if I [__] it up I can just put
wigs on it oh there's Tyson there's me
and Minnie me
that's what Tyson looks like yeah it
won't focus it was everyone's face is
just a big blurry we're at the club
I see that was it oh he had all his like
[__] he had [__] contacts and all
kinds of weird [__] I'm trying to get
this [__] to focus
yeah there he was
oh man yeah that was the whole thing
the Edgar behind you I haven't seen him
in a long time whatever happened Edgar
no I don't see Edgar isn't that Edgar no
it's a girl
that's a girl that looks like egg
and then that just reminded me I'm like
whatever happened to him is he all right
yes
what Edgar with a wife yeah Edgar yeah
he's around is he I haven't seen him I
thought he came to I thought he came to
um the club
I mean he does but I feel like I haven't
seen him in a long time yeah him and his
wife used to come out all the time okay
look they're gonna like her this this is
a a chick I've we've mentioned a couple
times on the show
wait this is me and Tori
oh yeah they're sorry all right I
haven't seen her in a lot yeah Tori was
like at a hurricane yeah that's me and
Tori that's [__] I was I was we were I
don't think we were a thing when I did
this one this is we maybe no we weren't
going out
then at this time
Tori
is
a real life Indian princess
she's a she's a macaw Indian
I heard which is up near Canada on the
Eastern Seaboard Mississippi Western
Seaboard around Washington
State and her dad is in like Indian
Affairs
and goes to Washington DC at all the
time
but yeah like in um Indians uh still
exist
and uh they're goth and she was the
[__] Puck rocker she was really cool
and she could dance like [__] she's
real good dancing she's super sweet yeah
I haven't seen her a long time yeah I
think her hair is blue now yeah last
time I saw her it was bright blue yeah
it's always some kind of [__] just
shock I loved the rainbow I loved the
rainbow though
but that must have been super heavy her
hair is a huge mane and it's all real
hair
it's not wigs and extensions
well it might she might have some
extensions in there huh maybe but I
thought it was a I mean she always kind
of seemed to like take part in like
doing it right she had it like rainbow
like that for a long time and I was just
kind of like oh my God better you than
me girl because I'm like that looks
super high maintenance but like for a
long time she mostly had it like bright
blue and that really looked nice the
last time I saw her was bright blue we
saw
at
um what was that last horror con we went
to
or no we saw her at that uh remember
that comic book shop
they had that big
uh [__] there where we were um
she was in a movie right yeah they were
showing the movie yeah yeah and we went
there and they were having like a whole
like horror thing where because I got
invited there to like uh sell my books
and [__] and she was there because they
were showing one of like a movie she'd
been like an indie movie this is me as a
blonde
next to next to our little lesbian
daughter that's what we used to call her
she's our little girlfriend that was
Kaylee and Kaylee died of cancer
see if I can get a picture of her yeah
yeah that was Kaylee
pork Haley
she just got eaten down to nothing
died at maybe 30 something maybe 31 32
34 34. yeah in this picture she's uh in
her 20s still
but that's what I look like blonde
I was maybe
39 there
yeah Zach said that's some dope as [__]
here about sorry about Terry yeah she
does have dope as [__] here yeah I
haven't seen her in a while but yeah
High Desert said I'm 53 we're the same
generation yeah yes there you go like I
said I'll be 51 next month
I'm getting digging deep deep into the
he's going back in here's another
picture of Dory Nostalgia another
picture there you see when Tina from
yeah
you got all kind of [__] in there yeah
this picture thori all right oh I
remember when her hair was like that
yeah there's another picture her hair
always looked like that but it was
always a different color yeah
I mostly remember her with blue hair but
I really yeah I remember that color too
for a while
yeah me and Tori
look how [__]
okay yeah
she's like
the thing is the coolest thing about
Tori is she is just like a super super
happy positive person yeah
she's just always happy and she's always
positive I got another picture of her
with black hair in here
Zach says Jen do you think you'll ever
let your hair go back to Ginger I'm
super jealous I'm not one how weird is
that
I might but it's probably gray at this
point
that's me and Tori that's Tori with
black hair
yeah that was just looking for more yeah
subtle
she's kind of well she's into goth ship
but she's kind of more into death metal
death metal and punk rock
so she would come out sometimes but she
mostly came to venue 13 when that's what
we used to see her all the time
it's another one I mean Dory
is her hair blue blue yeah see that's
what I mostly remember I remember the
blue hair
this is before me and you were a thing
me and Tori were hanging out at that
time we weren't officially dating but we
were hanging out
that only went on for about a
better well I don't know yeah I wasn't
really around I mean I was around but
yeah I didn't really know what was going
on
Zach said I always think with ginger
hair you don't got to do much [__] with
it for it to look good well
it's just like any other hair it's just
kind of like
you can't just leave it you can't just
have it like hang in there it doesn't
look good you always have to have it
like cut so it looks good
High Desert said it's time machine
Friday yeah I guess so Tom's getting
like all getting sentimental going back
into like the sentimental shade like
back into the day back into the day
but you know like a lot of those people
are actually like still around they're
still around yeah and they don't look
that different they don't look that much
not really I mean that's kind of the
weird thing about it you go out if you
go to like Barbarella which is not even
at the same place anymore
um On Any Given Saturday night like
probably 70 of those people will be
there yeah and they'll probably they'll
probably look pretty much the same as
they do in the picture
so
everybody's still doing this [__] even
though we're all old
like I said I was kind of like that's
why I kind of wanted to go to Barbara we
haven't been on a Saturday in a long
time
we go to Memento but that's Friday night
and I wanted to go to Saturday like I
said
I don't know it's a I have thought about
going back to my natural hair color but
like I said if I grow it back I just
kind of feel like it will mostly be just
like gray I think it'll probably be gray
at this stage
okay this is uh the photo shoot me and
Jen did
this we were just starting to go out
then we just started living together
actually
our friend Tony took this yeah our
friend Tony took that we did like a
whole we went over their place and he
had like the whole all the backdrops and
everything yeah
how old were you there Jen
well that was probably
um
I was probably like 40. yeah about 40.
it's over
you would never guess that she was 40.
maybe older but I'm not sure yeah
40 41 something like that yeah
I remember this I love this outfit
that's actually one of the favorite
pictures that one of my favorite
pictures that he took yeah because he
did a whole shoot
but that's probably my favorite picture
that he took of me
and we just took those like in him and
olathe's uh apartment
yeah because he had all the white
backdrops and everything we just went
over there one day and had a whole day I
made that belt for Jen yeah that's right
I still have it yeah I bought a lot of
this for you yeah I think it was a lot
of it was a gifts and stuff
yeah I had those boots for a long time I
don't have them anymore yeah wore them
out they still sell them I don't
remember those pants
I forgot about those no I still have
them you still have them okay yeah I saw
them you'll be able to fit it back into
them then I can fit him you fit in them
okay yeah
I never stopped fitting into those you
never okay because you were maybe what
115 pounds then maybe no I don't know I
never got that late 120.
125 around there no no I was probably
probably like 130 500 135 okay yeah
maybe yeah he looked great the latest I
ever got was getting there was 118.
you're getting back down to that and
that was a little while after that won't
be long and when I was 118 pounds I
looked a little bit she looked so skinny
sickly yeah
she looked better I'm not really built
to be that late Jen looked best at like
130 my ideal weight is about 135 140
pounds
that's when I that's when I feel like I
look
healthy and not too skinny
and I still fit in everything that's an
old picture you were skinny then
that was before the boobs yeah yeah
but the thing is is that it's uh the
resolution's too low so this
can't really see it it was a real crappy
photo
yeah she has one white eye and one black
eye
desert said wow those are really good
like the photos I guess yeah yeah like I
said our friend um yeah our friend Tony
took those
many years ago yeah he's still around
too we still didn't see him and his wife
well like I said Tony's wife was Tom's
ex-girlfriend yeah
he introduced them and then they later
they got married and they said they've
been together longer than we have
actually this was uh this was another
look that Jen was running for a while I
liked that one
I still have a shirt like that yeah it's
not that exact one but I have one that's
like almost exactly the same cut because
I liked that one so much that I ordered
another one when that one when that one
broke
because they don't last long the zipper
yeah the zippers all right breaks
because you know you try to zip it over
your tits and it's just like you know
the kind of yeah the tension uh so the
zipper breaks after a while it's from
that same era
I still have that shirt too yeah you
could have that corset still too yeah
and I still have that corset
and then that's a I think it's a bunch
of extensions or wigs um the back of it
is the front of it is my real hair but
the back of it no that might just be let
me see that
that's my actual hair I just teased it
but it just has a veil over it
that's my actual hair yeah that's when
she's around 130.
yeah this is not this is not very long
ago because this is at the place we just
left
yeah I was super skinny in there yeah
yeah but you'll be there in about a
month or so
at the rate that you're going yeah I
lost like 25 or 30 yeah
not eating it does wonders
ha
I mean I still eat just not that much
you know what I'm saying
look for some more pictures I gotta go
pee okay
and we'll show
all right
so you all know
then there was all this [__] going down
bro look at you that was just Jen
and uh
our friend
yeah
it was a boob Fest
her name was Sonya
oh yeah I remember this
that was me and my one of my [__]
Gotham dancing my ass off with blonde
hair
yeah remember there's like a [__]
bondage [__]
cinebite looking outfit that I had
all right
oh yeah yeah
that was Kaylee the one that died of
cancer
she was a little Texican girl
and the the redhead I'm forgetting her
name
um [__]
oh man
yeah forgetting her name but she's uh
she had a kid a few years back she's
still around
she's good
there's another one of miatori
yeah I'm in the chair look at Tori's
[__] hair okay remember that one
that's a [__] famous photo I'm
[__] thrashed look at my face
oh yeah
yeah I'm putting this one eyebrow it's
like I'm not drunk you're drunk what was
her name again what was her name again
she had she won
uh what's her name oh damn
um she was cute
Tyson was dating her yeah I know
ouch
um yeah she was a cutie I'll remember it
like I forgot her name no it's the same
same one the girl had the red hair that
was with yeah
yeah I'll remember it like 10 minutes
yeah
I'm honestly I'm amazed she married that
Cuban guy yeah I lost Costa her last
name is now Costa I think yeah I think I
think is what it was I've trying to
remember what her first name is man I'm
getting as bad as you yeah my memory
remember talking about Melissa my ex my
ex's friend yeah yeah that's Melissa
yeah you showed me that she was like the
one that reminded me of uh the girls
from [__] um
Ginger Snaps that was Melissa Melissa
was my best friend for [__] years she
was really cool that's what that's a
Mississippi goth right there
hanging out in New Orleans all the time
we all did that [__] yeah taking
pictures in the cemetery
I mean that's like the goth right of
pass yeah gotta go to the cemetery all
right she takes some [__] photos she
was talking about
my ex who I introduced to her husband
and that's them
yeah that's Tony that's the guy that
took those pictures yeah naturally
photographer
Genesis Jen has said in the past one of
the things that [__] made her [__]
like me is that I was friends with all
my exes still I was that's always a good
sign yeah because look if all of your
exes hate you then there's probably a
reason no I was friends with all my exes
and sometimes I date my exes everyone
was still like friendly towards you and
I was like well that's yeah promising
yeah because obviously you didn't do
anything too egregious to like really
piss them off well no usually it's just
that [__] didn't really quite work out
you know yeah I've never heard anything
from any of your exes that would be like
oh my God he was the worst or anything
like that nobody has said anything like
that but uh the one that I just showed
you um I lived with Elita for almost a
year and I love Elena she is [__]
awesome she's she is a sweetheart yeah
she's a uh a Content a a concept
they make Cornish yeah they also make
porn yeah I don't know if they've made
any in a while
yeah he sent me stuff that they made
recently recently oh okay yeah I'll show
it to you I've seen them at mannequins
yeah probably what was it like a month
ago they still come out just not us yeah
frequently okay I gotta I gotta show
them this one all right on the show over
time talked about this Disney princess
that [__] before me and Jen one thing
I was with Jen hated this [__] girl
God I really did yeah she hated this
girl and that was her she was uh one of
the Sleeping Beauties from up here at
Disney yeah
I know she's bad but I'm gonna [__]
hit
yeah
just men being men
that's always your excuse yeah we just
doing our thing man
earlier today when we were doing
streamate and we had some porn on over
there for atmosphere yeah and we had one
on that was
it was a Lexington Steele and
uh Sophie D Sophie D yeah it was
Lexington City yeah yeah Sophie D after
the Tom says to me and we'd been
drinking a little bit yeah he says to me
I'm I want to see a scene of you in
Lexington Seattle and I was just like no
you don't I was like yeah I didn't word
it that way what'd you say uh
I said I'm gonna get you to do a scene
so I'm gonna get you into a scene with
vaccines and then I said to you what did
I say to you
I was like he would you'd be over there
being like
yeah
and then you were like yeah that was
[__] that's just [__] up I was
like that would be the same as if I had
to watch a scene of you [__] some
other chick it's like I don't want to
watch that [__] either you don't want to
like watch me and Jen had messed around
[__] with with girls this is another
Mississippi girl that is yeah with other
girls not well you did well you kind of
did but not yeah like you know well look
that was that was Melissa's little
sister Michelle remember today there was
the two goth girls that kind of reminded
me of the girls from [__] yeah from
um Ginger Snaps
that was her that was her little sister
but though she's in this picture I think
she's probably
25 probably by then
she was old enough to go to the club so
she didn't drink so she was 21. I said
Tom looks like a super villain with the
blonde hair yeah he looks like a super
villain well he acts like a super
villain I am a supervillain he is yeah
he would probably be a worse super
villain if I wasn't here like [__]
smacking him down
being like don't do that [__] come on
oh remember I took this picture
me [__] I I posted that because [__]
Tyson fell asleep on my [__] bed
why is this [__] in my bed why is this
[__]
I remember I fell asleep on my [__]
day she sent that to me I sent it to you
I think I think you might I [__] clip
that thing and I [__] sent that to
you um
[__]
that's that's right on brand right yeah
yeah for him yeah
[Laughter]
DVD uh DB Dragon says damn you guys know
too many dead people [__] tell me
about it yeah well they were dying I
don't know what it is I don't think it's
particularly the god scene because it's
not like I mean I'm you know not gonna
lie I do know a couple of people that
have died from like drug overdoses and
stuff but
um most of the people that we know that
died roll young died of like cancer or
brain tumors or
um LD died in a car accident a free car
accident like some woman just like hit
him head on like while he was stopped on
a [__] on-ramp
and he died
all right I'm gonna tell you some of you
people who know what's up
this was my one of my friends in Boston
used to hang out with her she lived it
up the street from me but we used to go
to Man Ray a lot this is Tanya Fournier
she was she worked for Chanel she was a
[__] like top Chanel girl [__] in
the sales department she ended up
marrying marrying a Goths uh Rock uh
musician named Voltaire that's
voltaire's ex-wife Aurelio voltage
Aurelio voltario he's still around he's
out actually playing in Tampa because I
did a poster for his show yeah he's
playing in Tampa in next month October I
can't remember that was Tanya and Tanya
was [__] hilarious
he's engaged to a girl to a woman named
um what's her name mayumi
well because she's on his um YouTube
videos all the time that's another
picture of Michelle Melissa's sister
that must have been from um
around 2000 but that was like
for us you know we're talking about 2
000 Styles that's the way Goths looked
in 2000 yeah when I think that was
cutting edge style I kind of think of
that yeah more than right
whatever was going on with regular
people right and that picture is taken
in Mississippi that's actually Gulfport
Mississippi
so it was going down even in places like
Mississippi there were weirdos
everywhere yeah they're just [__]
everywhere everywhere there's an and
that was her older sister Melissa
and all this little like [__] I grew up
in Daytona Beach yeah I was the only
the only looking guy person well when I
got into high school
um
I don't know I kind of feel like I was
the only like super super goth person
but there was like a lot of other there
was people that were like in a punk and
yeah stuff like that
but not many this and I knew all of them
this was when I first moved here
oh look how cute you are Tom yeah hey
look that's what Zach was talking about
with the short sleeves on the long
sleeves yeah looks like he's got like
long sleeves and short sleeves yeah this
is when I first moved here and I just
started going to the clubs here long
sleeves and I was dating a kind of a
baby back girl who's taking that picture
that was Ashley love
that was me when I was just working up
the street here I remember that I
actually really like that picture yeah
yeah because he was working at the barn
raising horses and stuff with all the
horses
so there's like some
yeah
TV dragon dragon says Tori is like a
treasure troll that was me 1990.
[Music]
seven
97. I love it yeah it gossed out like a
mother God I love it almost like
something out of faith in the Muse I
love it yeah and I'm got [__] black
gloves with rings on and [__] see I
love that old school that was the old
school show I love that old school look
yeah and that was that's New Orleans
that set around that same time
yeah but we had the white makeup yeah I
remember that yeah I wore it a few times
but I still have some it's like it's
like bluish but
I try to keep it to a minimum because I
found that like putting white face on my
face like just makes my face look bigger
and rounder
so that's me [__] uh 2009
just up the street here
Dr math no no before that oh it's the
one we passed when we are on the club
and see see the house in the back yeah
that's where that's where me and Aleta
lived oh so that was the house we passed
yeah yeah
I was working those horses
yeah Tom is like here making this there
they are they're making all the lighting
[__] up they're the sisters together
too bad they're not around they'd be
[__] fun on the show
they'd be a lot of fun Melissa Michelle
I'm always bummed out by people that
were like in the god scene and then they
just like yeah out of it they're not out
though they're not out they're not out
they're still in there they're just [__]
uh Melissa has uh
got to be in her late 40s now well you
went and saw Melissa when you went to
see your dad yeah oh yeah hung out with
her yeah I thought you did her and her
boyfriend
I mean that was a couple years back now
but I remember you telling me that you
went there to see them that's Elena a
baby Aleta oh my God yeah before I knew
her in the cemetery in New Orleans
yeah that was before I knew her
okay that was even before I knew her
yeah
that was my cousin
she was got to
the runs in the family runs in the
family Zach says depending on when that
pick was taken what I was probably a few
months old LOL me and my first wife
Zach said I sent Tom an awesome as [__]
pic of a goth Viking
looked like it would make a great
costume for something yeah
and me you were all kind of messing me
Michelle and Melissa in the cemetery
taking pictures
yeah here it takes some pictures
1997 maybe I feel like the cemeteries
around here
yeah not real uh what not real
photogenic you're right let's call it
that
I will say that in Daytona
even though Daytona is lame they
actually do have a really nice very
photogenic cemetery and it's across the
street from a biker bar yeah so you
would probably
be into that because you could go to the
bike bar and then you'd go to like the
cool looking cemetery across the street
that's a later before I hooked her up
with her husband
matter of fact what she looked like
matter of fact the um
me dancing the club so you taking a
picture of it
before I met you
yeah long time I remember that outfit
now those and that outfit was old that
was uh
2009 Maybe
High Desert said I love old school goth
yeah we do too obviously
obviously I mean
you can still wear that [__] yeah it
should get away with it you can get away
with it it's just that they go yeah it's
kind of dated
yeah just like everything else it's like
kind of but like I said you could still
no one's gonna say anything to you if
you wear it like if you if you do it
upright
people be like oh yeah old school you
know what I mean but that was that was
uh Michelle dressed as Lilo
Melissa's sister
murder friends having trouble with his
feet yeah with his foot oh yeah yeah he
went foot's getting worse each day now I
got a fever and nauseous oh great that
was me and Elita
she hasn't worn that outfit in a long
time that was a long time ago oh that
was a long time yeah she carried a
little [__] stuffed animal with her
you know that was just the look and yeah
she's towering over me because she has
[__] huge platforms on
so murder Hornet probably are you gonna
like go to a doctor and see he's just
got what's going on with that he just
got out of the dot but still yeah
DVD Dragon says Tom has that same
charismatic pose in every shot like blue
steel from Zoolander
you should you should watch Zoolander
have you ever seen Zoolander oh my God
remember you should probably see that
remember that look
you had that yeah I remember that jacket
yeah it was a black velvet that looks
like is that the castle no that's uh
ibar
you were seeing me yeah because I
remember that was kind of around the
time that I first noticed yeah yeah yeah
because I was still married then right
I'm gonna put some more ice so I was
customized yeah I'm making more drinks
okay okay
because I was going to ibar at that
point I was still married to my first
husband and we would drive to we lived
in Daytona but we would drive to ibar
which was in Orlando which is about
a little less than an hour about an hour
drive so we go there like on Saturday
nights and I just started noticing Tom
um
you know the first thing that I noticed
one is like a cool dresser like he
always had like a really cool outfit on
and I'm really into like I said I was
really into old school goth [__] and I'm
particularly like dudes that would do
that because like I said a lot of girls
would do it
but it was much rarer to see a guy that
would do like an old school goth look
and honestly like we would go to the
castle a lot which is kind of like the
big golf club is it still there it's in
Tampa
and a lot of the dudes there they were
kind of like oh well you know they're
into all the goth industrial stuff but
it's like they don't want to dress up so
they would just kind of well we'll just
wear black jeans and like a you know an
industrial band t-shirt or something
like that and they would just call it a
day and I was just kind of like low
effort I'm really not into it so I liked
the fact that Tom would go like all out
like he had like velvet frocks and like
coats and all this other kind of stuff
and I'm like nice I like I like the cut
of that dude's jib you know what I mean
and then like he seemed to like dance to
all the same songs as me like because I
would hear a song like earlier than I'd
be like Oh I'm dancing to this
and like I go ahead and did them he'd be
dancing too and he'd know all the words
and [__] like that I'm just like all
right I'm impressed I like it I like it
and uh you know so just over time I was
just kind of like I'm intrigued by this
individual I must find out what what
this what's going on here because like I
said at this point me and my husband
were together for
um 14 years I would say 14 years so we
got married in 1990.
five 1995.
um when I was quite young so I was only
22 or 23.
and I'm not going to say it wasn't a
mistake or anything like that um you
know I would never say that
um but you know I was pretty young and
uh you know I don't know if I would do
it again if I had it to do over but I
don't regret it you know what I mean
because I did learn a lot
but
so we've been together a long time and
we were kind of having some problems and
I was just kind of like
you know I don't really know I was kind
of like at a Crossroads I guess and the
fact that I would even notice
another dude
I mean that kind of says something right
there because it's not
generally something that I do
like I said it was like nowadays like me
and Tom hanging out and stuff like that
it's like he'll check out chicks all day
long but it's like I'm not like a
checking out dudes type of girl I just I
just don't really do that and especially
if I'm with somebody
um I just don't really see the um
I don't know it's just not really
something that occurs to me so
the fact that
even though I was still married at the
time that I would even like check out
another dude or like be interested in
another dude that should tell you
something right there because that's
just I'm just not like that Tom knows
that I'm not like that yeah I'm just
talk about me
yeah yeah I'm just saying that the fact
that yourself she I did I didn't do I
didn't do anything bad I didn't like
cheat on my he thought I did who yeah he
thought so but he it was it wasn't true
but I didn't I didn't I didn't do
anything until me and my husband had
decided yeah we're not that's from Zach
oh yeah that's cool actually yeah that's
a real good picture they have a fly I
could do that that would fly very well
at the club I don't have any horns like
that I have some like kind of ram horns
yeah
but no big like yeah it looks really
good
it looks like there's a there's Norse
runes on it
looks good got that I like it from
things hanging from the antlers
my dad's got a bunch of those although
it's a little Marilyn mansony I will say
because her eyes are Whited out I think
that's probably but it's it's okay maybe
maybe we've maybe we've gone enough
length of time that people wouldn't
associate it with that yeah so it's just
kind of like because I don't want it to
have anything to do with that some of
that [__] that I showed you guys like
Elita dressed up and [__]
that was two thousand
no no
yeah around 2007. that's way ahead for
for the time that that photo was taken
the later was [__] ahead a lot in
fashion like this [__] that Zach just
showed that that's like spot on right
now you could you could wear that you'd
be like yeah that'd be badass
yeah but you had to wear the right
things with it
it'd be really good with like a black
black versions of almost some kind of
like fairy core like it's you know what
I mean uh wispy
yeah I can see that like folk horror
type but
warlock witch looking this is definitely
cool to do like a whole like folk horror
yeah like folk look black folk horror
looking like black fairy core looking
which reminds me I kind of want to
re-watch that folk horror documentary
that was on shutter I just haven't got
around to it because it's like three and
a half hours long in other words first
things that look like for
I do have those little I have do have
those little boot things yeah that are
black furry yeah they're black uh black
uh what do you call them
not velor
it's just like fake fur like fafer yeah
yeah murder Hornet saying that he hasn't
slept in three days because the pain is
so bad yeah High deserts that take some
THC gummies for the pain and to sleep
plus sleep knocks me right out
I wonder if that [__] works
I've never taken any of those THC
gummies I know there's like a big thing
now
I see ads for him everywhere
I'm not a big weed person
Ally well I've only smoked weed a few
times and I didn't like it but it's like
it might be I don't know I smoked it a
bunch of times and never was satisfied
with it that's what I mean like every
single time I was just always kind of
like hoping that it'd be better I'm like
it's not helping like I said the only
drug I really liked was it was some of
the [__] now [__] now is [__] super I
loved LSD but other than that some of
the shit's super strong and I kind of
thought it was too strong back then I
didn't want to move I was like yeah yeah
I don't like that kind of drug
it's kinda
it's kind of psychedelic but not not
good enough
you know a little too intoxicating
I like
real hallucinogens like [__] LSD you
don't even feel intoxicated you just you
feel normal it's just you start seeing
weird stuff you don't really feel normal
you feel good
but you just don't feel like you could
drive a car on it I wouldn't but you
could I wouldn't either yeah you could I
don't even like driving in the car you
can walk around normally and stuff
nobody would really know you were on it
yeah I'm not anything that and I know
that not everybody has the same reaction
and I think I've said this before but I
think that a lot of people like pop
because they it's like it chills them
out and stuff but it never did that to
me it always like made me more anxious
which I definitely don't need kind of
paranoid everybody knows that's what I
mean like it always meant like every
single time that I've done it it always
I was always kind of hoping that it
wouldn't do that but it always like made
me more anxious like everyone was
staring at me and it's like it made me
super self-conscious and I was just like
yeah I don't need
again
Zach says oh God now Tom has me looking
through old ass pics and I found ones
where I was stoned I just sent one
I don't think I have any stone pictures
unless somebody took one that I don't
know about
but
I don't think we took any when we were
tripping balls either did we
not that I remember
not that I remember I would hope that
nobody would do that to me but I don't
know
I don't know I'm sure that's like
there's tons of pictures of us drunk
but
as far as I know like the ones that
anybody posted or the ones that anybody
showed me like I didn't like sometimes I
was like Yay I'm drunk or nothing like
that but I didn't look like [__] up or
anything nothing like that poor one and
I still I don't know why I still
remember this but I still remember like
this one picture of this random girl
where I guess she got really drunk at
like some [__] Normie ass party and I
guess she um [__] herself and uh you
know instead of helping her
you know preserving her dignity or
everything like that Lord Knows No One's
Gonna Do that nowadays someone just like
took a picture of her and posted it to
the Internet so you know that was nice
so then it became a meme
so for some reason I was just kind of
like oh my God that's like my [__]
nightmare I've never been that Trump
before but I felt really really [__]
bad for that girl because I was like you
couldn't see her face at least I mean
that was a small consolation but
I was just kind of like holy crap I
would really hate it if
you know what I feel like if I was doing
because I've been drunk enough to do
some pretty stupid [__] okay like we've
all been there and um if anybody had
thought to like take a picture of that
and like post it on social media like
where my face was visible and stuff like
that I don't think that I would be
friends with that person anymore I'm
just saying because that's a pretty
shitty thing to do to somebody I'm gonna
do that at somebody look we've been with
friends that
got really drunk and nobody [__]
themselves but like some uh some other
things happen
that were um you know not also not great
it would probably be pretty embarrassing
if anybody knew about it but it's like I
never it never occurred to me for a
second to take a picture of that person
and put it online I just I don't know I
would I just wouldn't do that
and I feel like if you're friends with
somebody that would do that maybe you
shouldn't be friends with that person
anymore because that is a shitty person
you know I'm just saying don't don't do
that to your [__] friends that's not
your friend if they do that kind of [__]
to you taking pictures of your most
embarrassing moments like I said I've
been around some people that did some
embarrassing [__] I've done embarrassing
[__] when I was drunk
as far as I know nobody took a picture
of me and posted it online and I would
not do that either I just wouldn't
it's not cool not cool
TV tracks did I see that yeah you know
exactly what I'm talking about it's like
I just I think to myself at least the
girl I mean she was like face down in
the grass if I remember correctly I
haven't seen it in a while but I was
just like at least you couldn't see her
face so at least she had plausible
deniability she's like I just that's
totally not me
um because man
if that happened to me like I said
that's never happened to me but I've had
some embarrassing [__] happening when I
was drunk and I was just kind of like
man if somebody's taking a picture of
that and put it online oh that'd be the
[__] worse I would never go out again
because everybody just be thinking about
that
you know what I mean
[__] that
and [__] whoever took a picture of her
and then put it online maybe they didn't
know her but still
that's shitty don't do that to people
I don't know
people just suck more than people have
always sucked what am I talking about
people don't suck any worse than they
used to people always suck
oh [__] murder wanted said okay this is
a good story in 1997 I was screwing this
married chick probably not a good idea
uh just a booty call
okay uh I carried a call and call 357
Python he came home with caught us I put
the gun to his head
how do we get ourselves into these
situations I've never been in that kind
of situation
I've never been in that bad of a
situation I've been in some bad
situations but never that bad
um yeah he had a gun cabinet by the door
he punched through the glass I thought
he was gonna kill me he was losing that
oh [__] okay look it's um what after 10
and uh I got stuff I got to do
downstairs with his cooking okay but I
gotta tell you this story though okay
good because murder Hornet says
um
that in 1997 to tell you this in 1997 I
was screwing this married chick like you
said not a good decision yeah uh just a
booty call I carried a Colt 357 Python
he came home and caught us I put the gun
to his head he had a gun cabinet by the
door and he punched through the glass I
thought he was gonna kill me he came
close to losing his head so you're gonna
blow somebody's head off
because of some married chicks cooch
yeah so hold on one second though
hold on one second though yeah I'm
saying um do you want to continue to
host the show just let me go down and do
it or uh do you want to check off how
long is it gonna take oh the rest of the
night
oh yeah rest of the night about well not
the rest of the night half hour
oh okay so we're gonna yeah I'm gonna
make refried beans you want to eat some
oh yeah yeah I gotta eat all right well
we went on for almost three hours yeah
that's what I was saying it's been a
trip down memory lane yeah this evening
I'm having a good time but yeah a lot of
people dropped off anyway they want to
hear our old [__] well they're like we
don't know all these people what the
[__] going on I get it
sometimes they're mentioned on the show
over the years yeah
so all right so
um I guess what we're gonna do we'll do
a movie review Monday evening we might
talk about Meg too because we might go
see that on Monday
we're thinking about going to the
theater and seeing that on Monday so we
might talk about that or we might watch
something else I don't really know
um but yeah so hopefully you guys can
join us for that yeah High Desert said
I'm glad all my drunk days were
pre-internet right yeah I don't want any
people take a picture of me doing some
[__] because I got a burner on it all
right all right so thank you guys for
dropping by and hanging out with us this
evening hopefully you have a good
weekend and we'll see you again on
Monday night we're gonna do a movie
review like I said I don't know what
movie it's going to be but we'll all
find out together
so have a good weekend you guys and we
will see you on Monday evening good
night